Das war's für heute.
Ich habe jede Menge gefuttert, ich hoffe ich penn jetzt nicht ein im Stream, aber richtig.
Was gab es? Nudeln und Lachs, Bandnudeln und Lachs und China Sauce. Gürtel auf, ich habe gar
keine Gürtel hatten, ich habe so eine Jogginghose mit Gummi drinne. Da kann eigentlich gar
nichts drücken. Außer man ist viel zu fett, da kann immer was drücken. Ich glaube, ich
hätte sogar eine Pen sollen, da muss man mal gucken. Habt ihr mitbekommen? Es gab einen
Battlefield 2042 Season 4 Trailer. Da muss man wieder YouTube Hacker-Man machen, dass
es funktioniert, easy. Und der war so irgendwie relativ nicht-sagend, außer dass es eine neue
Map gibt und einen neuen Specialist. Wer hätte das gedacht? Irgendwie drei neue Waffen. Und
die Schiffmap wird überarbeitet, obwohl sie eigentlich Hourglass überarbeiten wollten,
aber sie haben wahrscheinlich festgestellt, Hourglass ist so eine Scheiß-Map, die müsste
man komplett neu bauen, damit man sie überhaupt benutzen kann und haben sich gedacht, nee,
wir lassen es einfach sein. Scheiß drauf, wir machen lieber das nächste Battlefield.
Weiß ihr was, ich glaube, für alle Beteiligten am besten gewesen wäre? Nicht unbedingt für
den Ruf von DICE, wobei der Ruf ist eh schon im Arsch. Wisst ihr, was das beste gewesen
wäre? Die hätten einfach Battlefield 2042 instant sterben lassen und hätten jetzt das
nächste rausgebracht dafür in gut. Dann wären auch alle wieder happy gewesen, weil aus dem
Game wird halt auch nichts mehr. Es ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, in einem Zustand, wo man sich
überlegen könnte, es demnächst vielleicht zu releasen. Ey, das will ich auch nicht,
das will ich auch nicht. Sie werden doch in der Lage sein, ein neues Spiel zu entwickeln,
also offensichtlich sind es ja nicht, aber das kann es ja nicht sein, aber sie werden
auch wohl in der Lage sein, ein neues Spiel zu entwickeln, wo die Essenz der Spiele schon
noch erkennbar ist, aber trotzdem was Neues bei rauskommt. Also sie sind ja offensichtlich
nicht in der Lage, aber das kann es ja nicht sein. Ich habe auch noch eine andere Sache
festgestellt wieder gestern, ich weiß, weil man nicht, ich glaube, ich werde hier nicht
auf Steam eingeloggt sein. Also ich habe gestern bestimmt, wobei, ich glaube, man sieht sogar
die Stats, man sieht sogar die Stats in Steam. Ich habe gestern in Steam, glaube ich, 170
Spiele in diesem Empfehlungssystem von Steam durchgeklickt und es war so gut wie nichts
dabei, was mich irgendwie interessiert hat. Es ist ganz ganz bitter eigentlich, wenn man
sich überlegt, dass es mehr Spiele gibt denn je, aber eine Sache, die mich bei Steam richtig
nervt ist und bei anderen Plattformen ist es egal, weil die nicht so viel Inhalt haben,
also da juckt es mich nicht, aber da ist es anders. Zumindest, was mich richtig nervt
ist bei Steam, dass du Early Access Spiele nicht richtig ausblenden kannst. Du kannst
zwar irgendwo in den Settings das einstellen, das bezieht sich dann aber nicht auf diese
Empfehlungsdinger für ein. Das heißt, ich habe diese, nee, kannst du nicht, du kannst
das ausschalten, aber die sind immer noch in dem Empfehlen, in diesem, ja, Chrome Add-on,
nee, ich meine ja im Steam Client selbst, ja das geht. Du kannst natürlich irgendwelche
Add-ons installieren, das ist trotzdem richtig bescheuert. So, Party Add-ons zählen jetzt
da nicht dabei. Also, wenn du das durchklickst, du kriegst 80% Early Access Zeug empfohlen
und ihr kennt mich, ich spiele aus Prinzip kein Early Access, weil einfach ein riesen
Prozentsatz der Early Access Spiele gar kein Interesse besteht, die jeweils mal irgendwie
fertig zu machen. Ich spiele aus Prinzip keine Early Access Spiele. Es gibt ganz wenig Early
Access Sachen, die ich gespielt habe. Mir fällt jetzt sogar, so spontan fällt mir gar
keins ein. Ich habe sicherlich die eine oder andere Early Access Sache schon gespielt,
aber mir fällt jetzt nichts ein, also ganz wenig. Ja, 2042, das könnte jetzt mal bald
in Early Access kommen. Man könnte sich überlegen, es vielleicht sogar bald zu releasen. Also
80% Early Access Shit, dann kriege ich, dann kriege ich ganz viel, wenn ich hier zum Beispiel
durchscrolle durch die Role-Playing-Section, sind 90% dieser Role-Playing-Dinger irgendwelche
komischen, irgendwelchen komischen Weep-Games im RPG Maker. Ja, wenn man hier zum Beispiel
aus RPG, RPG, New und Trending geht, die Hälfte sind irgendwelche komischen Weep-Games.
Division 2, ja weil das auch so New ist, ja. Jetzt gehts los, jetzt kommen nur noch Weep-Games
und das meiste da vorne irgendwelche komischen RPG Maker-Dinger. Demon Queen Melissa, genau
das, das hat er mir gestern auch empfohlen. Steam, du willst mir noch nicht allen Ernstes
erzählen, dass ich Demon Queen Melissa, dass das jetzt die Empfehlung ist schlechthin worauf
ich mein Leben lang gewartet hab, das zu spielen oder was? Milky Quest, ist die Stupide? Oh
Mann, naja gut. Nix gegen Weep-Games, aber die Empfehlungen von Steam sind schon etwas
tragwürdig. Es ist, es ist, ich weiß nicht, ich hab mir das früher ganz anders vorgestellt.
Ich hab das Game nicht mal probiert, das ist richtig. Ich hab überhaupt, ich muss nicht
alles ausprobieren um einschätzen zu können ob das für mich sich lohnt oder nicht. Weil
du hast auch noch nicht probiert dich vom Auto überfahren zu lassen. Du kannst aber auch
davon ausgehen, dass es wahrscheinlich eher nicht das ist, was du machen willst. Ich kann
das bei Games mittlerweile auch ganz gut einschätzen, ob das was ist, was ich spielen will oder
nicht. Arbeitsplatz ergonomisch einrichten, die Arbeiterkammer Österreich. Okay, seriously,
das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, aber das muss ich mir mal aufpassen. Ich will wissen,
was die Arbeiterkammer Österreich, wusste mir es eben vor zwei Sekunden nicht, dass
es das gibt. Ja, es gibt so viele Spiele wie noch nie und es gibt durchaus auch die ein
oder andere gute Spiele. Es ist aber sehr schwer das zu finden. Also der Wust auf Steam, durch
was man sich da durchklicken muss, da ist so viel Shit dabei, man. Ich glaube ich werde
einfach zum 520. Mal Half-Life durchspielen oder so demnächst. Weil ich irgendwas zum
Spielen brauche. Aktuell spiele ich erstmal noch Dead Space fertig. Lupus, der ist schon
für den Sub. Aktuell spiele ich erstmal mal das Dead Space Remake fertig. Da brauche
ich aber nicht mehr allzu lange für. Ich kenne das Original, ich weiß, dass es nicht
mehr allzu lange dauert. Ich muss aber eins sagen. Zu cool ich das Dead Space Remake finde,
ich werde da wahrscheinlich kein eigenes Video zu machen, weil der Game ist jetzt schon zu
lange raus, das interessiert keinen mehr. Aber so gut ich das Remake finde, also die
haben das wirklich gut eingefangen und auch die Neuerungen, die sie drinnen haben, dass
man beispielsweise jetzt das Raumschiff komplett begehen kann oder dass man vielfältiger seine
Waffen upgraden kann. Das ist vielleicht nicht mehr ganz, also es ist immer noch sehr linear,
man rennt ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit im Questmarker hinterher auf X. Aber nicht mehr ganz so
krass linear wie das Original. Aber so gut ich das Remake finde, es ist okay, es gibt
viel schlechtere Remakes. Ich muss sagen, mehr Horror-Feeling hatte ich im Original.
Mag natürlich auch daran liegen, dass ich das Original schon zwei, drei Mal durchgespielt
habe und beim vierten Mal Dead Space jetzt vielleicht auch nicht mehr so krass horrormäßig ist.
Wobei ich eigentlich darauf gehofft habe, dass durch die bessere Grafik und auch die
bessere Beleuchtung, dass es auch mal irgendwie sich wie ein anderes Game spielt. Macht es,
macht es aber nicht wirklich mehr Horror. Ich muss auch sagen, es ist zu dunkel. Das
Original Dead Space war auch schon dunkel, aber das Remake ist dank besserer Beleuchtungs-Engine
und sowas. Zwar besser beleuchtet, realistischer beleuchtet, aber auch zu dunkel für meinen
Geschmack. Also ich habe im Original selten gehabt, dass ich permanent mit gezückter
Taschenlampe rumgelaufen bin. Man kann ja wenn man rechts klickt und aimt, hat man so
eine Taschenlampe. Die Sounds sind tatsächlich fast noch besser als im Original, aber das
mag vielleicht auch an Frostbite liegen bzw. die Leute, die daran mitgearbeitet haben.
Eins konnte DICE, ich weiß jetzt nicht von DICE das Remake, aber DICE und Frostbite
haben ja eine lange Historie, was guten Sound angeht. Also vielleicht haben da die eine
oder andere Leute mitgearbeitet daran, die wissen wie man guten Sound in Frostbite macht.
Also der Sound ist wirklich gut. Allerdings manchmal, das kann aber auch im Original
gewesen sein, da bin ich mir wirklich sicher, manchmal auch zu übertrieben. Also es passiert
eigentlich gar nichts wildes, aber die Musik macht im Hintergrund und du denkst dir, ja
okay und jetzt passiert doch gar nichts. Ich glaube das war im Original aber auch schon
so. Führerschein kam an, Moment, Fahrzeugschein kam an, Freitag ist Abholung, Pogu. Dann
ist Tesla Time angesagt. Also kann man sich aber auf jeden Fall gönnen, wenn man Dead
Space mochte, gerade wenn man Dead Space einige Jahre nicht gespielt hat oder gar wenn man
das noch nie gespielt hat. Also wenn man das noch nie gespielt hat, würde ich auch sagen,
spielt vielleicht eher das Remake als das Original, aber unterm Strich, unterm Strich
muss ich sagen, hätte Dead Space 1 kein Remake gebraucht, ich glaube das trifft es eigentlich
ganz gut. Das Spiel ist fresh genug, das hätte nicht wirklich ein Remake gebraucht. Hast
du schon gehört, dass Windows 11 eingestampft wird? Ist schon 1. April? Windows 11, okay
zeig mal her. News. Nö, wird nicht eingestampft, nicht eingestampft. Sonst würde es in News
stehen. Nice, gb8 vom Chat. Auf Chip gab es ein... Okay, was sagt denn Chip? Okay, das
muss ich mir jetzt sagen, zeig mir Chip. Windows. Ja, für irgendeine alte Version wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich für die Release Version oder sowas. Und doch zieht Microsoft mal... Das
ist gb8, das erkennt, ich rieche den gb8 meilenweit aus dem Titel schon, Alter. Das ist gemein
ist Windows 11, 21h2. Microsoft aktualisiert sein... Habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass ich
Autoplay einfach kacke finde? Ich habe doch genau das schon vermutet. Es geht nicht darum,
dass Windows 11 abgeschafft wird oder eingestellt wird. Es wird irgendeine outdated Version
von Windows 11, den Support eingestellt. Ja, super, nice. Da war ja auch mit... Zum Teufel
komme ich auf einmal auf Lost Ark. Damit war ja auch irgendwo zu rechnen, oder? Massive
gb8. Chip, Alter. Oh, das... Appletroll 2605, danke für den Sub. Richtig dicke gb8. Richtig
falsches Emote. Richtig dickes gb8 war das von Chip. Er schreibt, ich habe bei Idealo
ein Windows 11 Key für 4€ gefunden. Ist das legit? Höchstwahrscheinlich nicht. Was nicht
heißt, dass der Key nicht gehen wird. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall Grauzone. Dass der Key
geht, ist durchaus möglich. Wie findest du ASMR Programming? Du wirst lachen. Ich habe
sogar schon die ein oder anderen ASMR Programming Videos geguckt. Zum Beispiel kann ich mich
noch dran erinnern, ich habe mal ein Video geguckt. Das ist natürlich, fragt man sich
natürlich wie mich das entspannen kann. C++ ASMR habe ich schon mal geguckt.
Kann man sich kaum vorstellen, dass ich C++ ASMR entspannen finde. Tatsächlich, wartet
mal. C++ ASMR. Passt mal auf. Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung. Guck mal hier. ASMR C++
Programming. Da wird C++ C++ Programmed. Eigentlich wird nur C out gemacht. Wer kommt
auf sowas? Das Internet. In dem Fall kommt Caroline ASMR auf sowas. C++ ASMR Programming.
Also wie gesagt, ich kenne das nicht so. Ich weiß, dass es das gibt. Ich habe sogar selbst
schon so Sachen geguckt. Warum auch nicht? Ganz im Ernst, ich finde es relativ entspannend,
jemanden beim tippen zuzuhören. Wenn der natürlich nicht drauf rumschlägt, sondern
es ordentlich tippt, finde ich das eigentlich ganz... Oh, das müssen wir gleich mal überbriefen.
Rust ASMR. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Chess Engine. ASMR Programming. Building Chess AI from scratch.
Zwei Millionen Views. Der Typ hat die gleiche Tastatur wie ich. Und Wim. Wim. Okay. Der
weiß schon mal, wie es geht. Der weiß schon mal, wie es geht. Moment, das ist nicht die
Tastatur, die ich habe. Sieht aber recht ähnlich aus. Ordentliche Tastatur. Wim. Und Rust. Placingly
fast written in Rust ASMR. Wie das einfach zwei Millionen Views hat. Das ist ja fast
so viel wie mein Gartenstells Video. ASMR Programming. Tja, das ist ja mal, Leute. Habt ihr wieder
was gelernt, was es nicht alles gibt? Richtiger Giga-Chat. Ja, da hast du schon mal gesehen,
der weiß, was er macht. Ich hoffe, es war Neo Wim. Weil sonst kommt die Rust Task Force
von Hacker News und flamet ihn, wie er was anderes als Neo Wim verwenden kann. Moment,
es gibt schon eine Reaktion? Oder meinst du jetzt meins jetzt? Oder wie? Eventuell eine
ganz blöde Frage. Was hältst du von MacBooks für die Dev-Arbeit? Ich finde MacBooks, also
ich benutze keine MacBooks. Nehmt das mal mit einer Portion Skepsis. Ich finde das nicht
schlecht. Auch wenn ich keins selbst benutze. Aber wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen MacBook
oder Windows, dann würde ich eindeutig MacBook nehmen. Weil Mac hat den Vorteil, es ist,
ich nenne es mal Linux-mäßig genug. Es ist kein Linux, es ist ja eine BSD drunter. Aber
so Unix-mäßig genug dafür, dass Arbeit auf der Kommandozeile und die üblichen Tools
alle vorhanden sind und Bock macht. Und du hast eine ordentliche Oberfläche. Man könnte
sagen, ja klar, du kannst auch Windows verwenden mit WSL. Ja, geht auch. Wobei ich persönlich
würde tatsächlich MacBook vorziehen als Windows. Ja, ist schon okay, kann man machen.
Hier oben, ich habe eben noch eine andere Frage oben übersehen. Mona, ich denke für den
Zeitraum, irgendwas hat hier oben einer mit Tools gefragt. Das habe ich gesehen, aber
dann, ah hier, genau. Hey Max, der echte Joseph, bist du noch da? Wenn du schon weg bist, muss
ich jetzt auch nicht mehr zeigen, aber kann ich was zu sagen? Ich wollte dich mal fragen,
wie die Tools heißen, mit denen du deine Systemlast oben rechts in der Ecke unter Archive. Ich
würde das Ganze gerne mal nachbauen. Das kann ich dir zeigen. Hä, bei mir hast du auf
einmal eine andere Farbe als da oben, aber gut, man versteht es nicht unbedingt. Ich
habe etwas Neues entdeckt, wo wir gerade dabei sind, zeige ich euch das mal schnell, bevor
wir dann zu Endeavor OS kommen. Das da oben nennt sich in GitHub, a bumblebee status,
heißt das Projekt. Ich habe aber noch etwas Cooles entdeckt und zwar, das hier ist eigentlich
gar nicht so sinnvoll zu verwenden, sondern es ist besser, anstatt dem CPU Modul CPU2
zu verwenden. Und das kann nämlich was recht Cooles, ich zeige euch das gerade mal. Gestern
nämlich mal die Liste der eingebauten Module angeguckt und zwar kann man CPU Layout, also
anstatt CPU, CPU2, CPU2 Layout, da kann man jetzt sagen, man möchte Coreload haben, sondern
jetzt reloade ich das. Ups, achso, ich bin ja auch blöd, ich hab hier nen. Jetzt reloade
ich das mal, guck mal, jetzt habe ich keine CPU Auslastung im klassischen Sinne mehr,
sondern ich hab hier sowas. Und das zeigt die Auslastung per Core in so einem Graph,
das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen, sag mal, ich mach mal ordentlich Auslastung, bäm,
Vollauslastung, da seht ihr, zack, alles ausgelastet, ich mach jetzt mal, dass man es vielleicht
ein bisschen besser sieht, ich mach jetzt mal ein bisschen Auslastung. Guckt, finde
ich eigentlich viel cooler, als da 100% CPU Last oder so stehen zu haben. Also wenn das
Ding alles oben am Rand ist, siehst du ja auch, dass es 100% CPU Last ist. Finde ich
eigentlich viel angenehmer, als so ne reine Prozentanzeige. Also manchmal entdeckt man
auch noch Sachen, die eingebaut sind. Das wackelt jetzt natürlich wild hin und her,
weil ich hier, ja ich sag, das ist Bumblebee-Status, hat ein sehr hässliches Logo, gut, soll wahrscheinlich
ne Biene sein, aber er könnte sich von irgendeinem AI mal ein ordentliches Logo designen lassen,
aber mittlerweile kein Ding, wenn du keinen Bock hast auf Fiverr zu gehen oder irgendjemand
wirklich zu fragen, der dir aber hilft. Aber das finde ich sehr praktisch, ja. Normalerweise
sieht das natürlich nicht so aus, ja. Normalerweise sieht das so aus. Also fast keine Last und
manchmal ein bisschen Last drauf. Also wir machen mal beispielsweise ein YouTube Video
drauf. Ah, machen wir hier mal ein YouTube Video an. Oder machen wir mal irgendwas mit
ein bisschen mehr Bewegung. Battlefield, ja, da passiert ein bisschen. Ach, da muss ich,
ich muss euch was fragen. Mir fällt, das ist kein Polybar-Modul. Das, das, das, das ganz,
die Status-Leiste nennt sich Bumblebee-Status. Das ist nicht Polybar. Das ist ein, ein E3-Status
-Leiste. Noch gar nicht installiert. Das ist noch mal normales. So, guck, hier oben seht
ihr jetzt halt, dass es ziemlich viel CPU-Auslastung verursacht, einfach nur Videos abzuspielen.
Leute, ich muss euch mal was fragen. Vielleicht habt ihr da eine glorreiche Idee. Guckt mal,
ich hab hier Firefox offen und ich guck mein letztes Battlefield-Video an. Das hab ich
gerendert, mein Battlefield-Video hab ich gerendert, 1044p, 60 FPS. So weit, so gut.
Jetzt, pass mal auf, jetzt mach ich Firefox unter Windows auf, mach das gleiche Video
an. Also ich hab bei mir, im Firefox, hab ich nicht 1440p zur Auswahl. Ne, ne, ne, ne,
ich hab das überprüft. Ich habe hier direkt vorm Umlocken kein 1440p gehabt und ich hatte
bei keinem Video 1440p im Firefox. Ich hatte nur maximal 1080p. Hä? Vielleicht ist es
ein Bug. Vielleicht hat sich ja kein Firefox aktualisiert oder so. Ok. Ok. Man weiß es
nicht. Teil 1 ist viel besser. Teil 1 ist mit Abstand der beste Dead Space Teil. Den
Rest kannst du vergessen, den Rest haben sie nur gemacht, weil es Geld bringt. Gut, tatsächlich
Spiele werden hauptsächlich entwickelt, man muss unterm Strich Geld machen, aber Dead Space
2 wurde nur gemacht, weil der erste Teil so erfolgreich war, dass Dead Space 1 mit Abstand
das beste und eigentlich auch das einzige, was man davon spielen sollte, müsste, muss,
was man gespielt haben muss, so rum. Spielen sollte, man kann ja jeder spielen was er will,
aber das einzige Teil, den man gespielt haben muss davon, ist eigentlich Dead Space 1. Den
Rest, den Rest, finde ich, kannst du eigentlich knicken. Man sieht es ja schon daran, dass
die mit Dead Space 2 und 3 und so mit komischen Multiplayer Shit und so angefangen haben,
als hätte Seriously irgendjemand bei Dead Space jemals nach Multiplayer gefragt. Ja, das stimmt,
ich bin tatsächlich relativ oft on gerade. Ich habe Chat-GPT in meinem Terminal und ich
frage da manchmal Dinger, ja. Wir haben auch schon im Stream mal Dinger gefragt, meistens
ist es nicht so super hilfreich. Außer fürs Beschreiben von Terminal-Commandos, da ist
es ganz praktisch, da geht es schneller als in die Manpage gucken. Lange nicht da gewesen,
wie man im MMO Fachjargon so sagt. Pateroheri, danke schon für den Sub, 27 Monate, Pongos.
Ja dann. Wie viel Thala bekommt man, ist eine gute Frage, guck mal mal, Steam, BF2042,
was wollen die da aktuell eigentlich für haben noch? 109 Euro. Also ich weiß nicht
was mit den, ja vor allem den 1-Jahres-Pass. Lull. Alter das Jahr ist rum, warum sollte
man sich den 1-Jahres-Pass kaufen? Alter ist das hängen geblieben, Mann. Dann kauft euch
lieber Titanfall 2, das hat nämlich eine richtig gute Kampagne. Na gut.
Tja. Weiß nicht, was Twitch sich denkt, was man damit so machen soll. Also ich gucke
ja ganz gerne Krabi, früher, ich wollte gerade sagen Follow Krabi, jetzt mittlerweile heißt
es nur noch Krabi, das ist ein niederländischer Warcraft-Streamer, in letzter Zeit eher Dota
und sowas und der macht das so, der hat zu Weihnachten irgendeine Aktion, wenn die Leute
glaube ich 100.000 oder es könnte auch eine Million, ich weiß es nicht, es ist auf jeden
Fall jede Menge Kanalpunkte gesammelt haben, dann schickt er ihnen eine Weihnachtskarte,
aber theoretisch könnte ich ja auch sowas machen, aber ihr wisst es, ich bin viel zu
faul, ich will nicht irgendwas versprechen, was ich dann am Ende nicht mache.
Deutscher Datenschutz sagt nein, der Datenschutz sagt nur nein, solange die Leute nicht ihre
Einverständniserklärung dazu geben, das muss man dann halt sagen. Natürlich, in Rust,
was sonst, man kann ja prinzipiell neue Software nur noch in Rust entwickeln, alles andere
ist ja nicht mehr erlaubt. Alter, was ist das für spookige Musik im Hintergrund? Irgendeine
Mario Kart Strecke. Ja, ja, das ist aber nicht, das ist aber die falsche Strecke. JoyitSBCESP,
ich will damit meinen Stromverbrauch fotografieren, dann umwandeln in einen Graf, warum muss es
ausgerechnet ein JoyitSBCESP, ach so, weil das einer mit Kamera ist. Davon habe ich auch
noch einen hier liegen, genau so einen, habe ich auch noch hier liegen. Das macht aber ehrlich
gesagt, du willst wahrscheinlich das hier verwenden, oder? Vermute ich jetzt mal, dass
du das hier verwenden willst, dieses Projekt. Das habe ich auch ausprobiert, da hatte ich
keine allzu guten Resultate drin. Das ging, aber ging auch mal nicht, also war jetzt nicht
so der Wahnsinn. Kennst du eine Möglichkeit, Ads in der YouTube App zu blockieren? iOS,
also ja und nein, also du kannst nicht so ohne weiteres mit einem Adblocker arbeiten, selbst
wenn du Sachen wie Edgard Home oder Piehole oder so verwendest, das geht ja prinzipiell
für Apps auch, weil es ja über DNS geht, aber die Apps beziehungsweise die Contentanbieter
sind mittlerweile clever genug, gerade Twitch ganz vorne weg, die integrieren das so, dass
die Werbung nicht mehr über extra Server läuft und dementsprechend kannst du es auch per
DNS Block nicht mehr blocken. Was du machen kannst ist folgendes, du könntest YouTube
im Browser verwenden, allerdings finde ich persönlich YouTube im Browser abartig zu
benutzen auf dem Smartphone, das liegt aber auch daran, weil ich den Eindruck habe, dass
YouTube absichtlich, so ein bisschen wie Reddit, Reddit macht das, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
auch, muss man die Seite genauer analysieren, oder sie sind einfach nur unfähig, aber dass
die die Bedienung per Smartphone Browser absichtlich Scheiße machen. Gerade Reddit, ich verstehe
nicht, wie eine publische Forumsseite wie Reddit so schlecht über dem Browser bedienbar
gemacht werden konnte auf dem Handy. So, und was du machen kannst ist, und das klingt jetzt
vielleicht nach ein bisschen gecheated, wenn ich dir das sage, aber du kannst dir YouTube
Premium holen, du musst YouTube Premium nicht in Deutschland kaufen, du kannst YouTube Premium
in Indien holen, das kostet dann irgendwie 3,20€, du musst das noch nicht mal über
einen VPN machen, wobei doch, das stimmt nicht, du musst es über einen VPN machen, das ist
plötzlich was erzähl ich dir, ich mache es nicht über einen VPN, ich hole mir immer
bei Digital Ocean eine VM in Bangalore, das ist in Indien, und tunnel dann da rüber mein
Browser Traffic, ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche wie VPN für die Seite, und da kannst
du dir für irgendwie 3€ oder so im Monat, oder noch, es ist auf jeden Fall wirklich
billig, es kostet YouTube Premium in Indien, guck mal nochmal, über Argentinien kostet
es 1€ im Jahr, es ist, es ist, sind es Rupiers, nee keine Ahnung, zumindest ist es billig,
das ist wahrscheinlich die stressfreiste Variante, die du haben kannst, indem du dir einfach
YouTube Premium über in Indien holst, und das coole ist, Alter, MonkaS was ist mit der
Musik los, nee jetzt nicht, viel angenehmer, wir machen einfach die Top 25, die sind bestimmt
viel geiler, ja man könnte sagen, das ist ein bisschen gecheatert, weil es ja nicht
wirklich Ads blockt, aber du hast dann einfach keine Ads mehr, das ist tatsächlich die
einfachste Variante, du holst die jetzt über YouTube Indien, und du hast noch einen weiteren
Vorteil, YouTube Music und sowas ist dann dabei, und dementsprechend auch werbefrei
und alles mögliche, also du kannst quasi auch, du brauchst dann auch gar kein Spotify
und kein Amazon Prime Music oder sonst was mehr, du kannst auch einfach die YouTube Music
Tab verwenden, also das Paket ist wirklich nicht schlecht, für 3 Euro oder für 14 Euro
im Jahr, kann man schon machen, das einzig blöde, wenn du YouTube Music verwendest,
die New and Trending, das New and Trending Tab ist dann halt Bollywood Musik, weil du
in Indien bist, ist aber nicht schlimm, weil da gucke ich eh nie drüber, und nachdem du
ein paar mal deine Lieblingsmusik angeklickt hast, empfiehlt es dir auch nur noch deine
Lieblingsmusik, die du magst, wenn du halt unter New and Trending guckst, ist es halt
Bollywood Indisches Zeug, das ist keine wirkliche Alternative zu der Frage von ihm, guck mal
wenn jemand ein iPhone hat mit iOS drauf und will YouTube werbefrei gucken, ist es zwar
möglich sich ein Android Handy zu kaufen, das ist aber für ihn keine ernsthafte Alternative,
das wäre ungefähr damit zu vergleichen, wenn sich einer beschwert, bei meinem Streaming
Anbieter gibt es keinen Originalton und irgendjemand sagt, ja dann kauf doch einen Flug in die
USA und guckst da zur Premiere, anstatt ihm zu sagen, hol dir einen VPN oder geh über
ein Proxy, kann man das eigentlich auch noch mit anderen Abos machen, du meinst sowas
wie YouTube Premium über Indien, ehrlich gesagt kein Plan, das habe ich mir noch nie
angeguckt, also prinzipiell kann es es woanders natürlich auch machen, aber ich mach es nirgends
woanders so, ja und dann muss das aber alle sieben Tage erneuern, ist es nicht so, dass
auf iOS sich sideloaded Apps sieben Tage später wieder löschen, wenn du die nicht automatisch
mit ein paar Klicks renewst öfters, ich glaube das ist unter anderem der Grund warum PC Apps
immer schlechter gemacht werden, weil die wollen gar nicht, dass die Leute mehr am PC
das ganze verwenden, weil du kannst am PC so DRM nur wirklich schwer komplett so entforcen
mit irgendwelchen fertigen Boxen oder Smartphones ist das viel einfacher, gerade Smartphones
wo du auch keinen Rutsuchegriff drauf hast, guck mal, du kannst beispielsweise relativ
easy einen Copyright geschützten Film auf dem PC abgreifen, also scheiß auf DRM und
andere Sachen und HDCP, PC gibt es immer Möglichkeiten, bei einem Android TV die irgendwie
einen HDCP Handshake machen, über das Kabel und dann nur noch ein Abspielgerät das ganze
lesen kann, sieht es nicht unmöglich, ich weiß es sieht schon viel schwieriger aus
und bei einem Smartphone, wenn der Hersteller sowas nicht vorsieht, ist ja nahezu, wenn
du keine Hutmöglichkeiten hast, unmöglich, deswegen sind die auch glaube ich so hinterher,
dass die Leute immer weniger ihre Desktop für so Sachen verwenden, weil du als Anwender
viel weniger Kontrolle auf dem Desktoprechner hast, als auf irgendwelchen vernagelten Boxen.
Aber da machen wir natürlich nicht mit Leute.
Es ist doch ganz einfach, wenn die einen zu sehr gangeln, entweder konsumiert man den
ganzen Scheiß nicht mehr, was ich an ganz vielen Stellen mache oder man nimmt die einfachste
Variante, die einfachste Variante ist entweder eine selbst erstellte Sicherheitskopie wieder
zu Restore oder ein VPN in ein anderes Land, wo das Angebot besser ist, was man von dem,
was man gucken will.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wenn sie es nicht auf die Reihe kriegen und ich
sehe es halt auch nicht ein, mir sieben verschiedene Streaming-Anbieter zu holen.
Nein natürlich, natürlich, jetzt kann man dagegen einwenden, ja du musst dir auch nicht
sieben verschiedene Streaming-Anbieter holen, du musst dir immer nur den Streaming-Anbieter
holen, wo es gerade das gibt, was du gucken willst und kannst dann wieder kündigen.
Das stimmt, aber es ist trotzdem so, dass sich das auf sieben, acht verschiedene Plattformen
erstreckt und dann musst du dann quasi Streaming-Anbieter Abos jonglieren.
So nach dem Motto, ah, heute, Moment, Moment, dieses Mal mache ich Apple TV, jetzt mache
ich, jetzt will ich irgendwie, was weiß ich, The Boys, Amazon, jetzt muss ich Netflix machen,
aber dann muss das, wenn ich mich vergesse zu kündigen und so, es ist irgendwie doof.
Ja Caelor, wir haben es verstanden, dass du zu Sachen gerne guckst.
Hast du Empfehlungen für ein VPN?
Ne, will ich nicht machen.
Alternativ Frontends, also ich benutze gar kein VPN, ich mache das folgendermaßen, das
ist aber, ah, interessant, das könnte man sich vielleicht auch mal angucken.
Also wie ich das mache, ist folgendermaßen, ich hole mir meistens eine VM bei Digital
Ocean, die haben weltweit, es ist egal wo die dir das holen, ich mache es ganz gerne
bei Digital Ocean und hole mir eine VM und tunnel mein Browser drüber, das ist total
einfach mit einem Socks-Proxy, du musst nichts installieren auf der VM, du brauchst einfach
nur eine SSH-Verbindung, du kannst mit ssh-n-d, glaube ich, kannst du ein Socks-Proxy aufmachen
über den Tunnel und dann stellst du dein Browser auf den Proxy um und dann kannst
du mit dem Browser über deine VM surfen.
Was ist denn nochmal minus n, dachte man, braucht minus d und minus n, ah, Compression
ist für Filme und so doch egal, yep, minus d, habt ihr denn einen Tipp, bevor wir uns
Endeavor erst ankommen, habt ihr denn einen Tipp für einen guten Mobilanbieter, der,
ich habe ja wie immer, ihr kennt mich, ich habe ja so ein paar Ansprüche, der eSIM unterstützt
und der Multisim unterstützt, ich weiß es bisher nur sicher von der Telekom, dass die
das machen und Vodafone, Multisim für LTE-Backup, zum Beispiel, ja, ok, Chainlord, von denen
habe ich noch nie was gehört, taugen die, wait, woher wissen die, wie ich heiße, gut,
das ist ein Bild, das ist ein Bild, die wissen nicht, wie ich heiße, das ist einfach, das
ist einfach nur Zufall, das ist einfach nur Zufall, dass da Maximilian steht, aber um
es euch zu beweisen, im Cocklitomodo steht da auch Maximilian, ja, aber es hat mich jetzt
erstmal schon ein bisschen irritiert, muss ich sagen, Illuminati, ok, und die können
Multisim und eSIM, ok, eSIM, eSIM, haben die Multisim auch, ja, also Multisim aus zwei
Sekunden, ich kann euch sagen, warum ich, können die Multisim, ne, Chainlord erzählt
wieder zu euch, die können gar kein Multisim, oder, ne, by the way, die Seite sieht gewöhnungsbedürftig
aus, also, warum ich den Anbieter mit Multisim will, ist folgendes, ich habe hier aktuell
noch ein iPhone von der Arbeit, mit einer Nummer, die ich seit 8 Jahren oder 10 Jahren
wahrscheinlich fast schon verwende, die Rufnummer will ich mitnehmen auf ein eigenes Handy jetzt
und brauch ich natürlich einen eigenen Vertrag für, und das ist auch kein Ding, das hab
ich mit denen schon geklärt, also umziehen, umziehen ist ok, kann man machen, jetzt brauch
ich halt nur einen Vertrag für, so, und warum ich eSIM haben will, Option ist ganz klar,
ich hab kein Bock mit SIM-Karten rum zu hantieren, und warum ich Multisim haben will, ist ganz
einfach erklärt, ich will die Möglichkeit haben, also ich will zwei Sachen damit machen
können, ich will die Möglichkeit haben, es in zwei verschiedenen Handys benutzen zu können,
falls ich nämlich von meinem neuen Arbeitgeber auch wieder ein Handy kriege, also was so ist,
weiß ich schon, auch kriege, dann könnte ich meine SIM auch da drauf machen, dann könnte
ich quasi wieder nur ein Gerät verwenden, halt mit zwei Telefonnummern, oder, das ist
auch was, was ich machen will, ich könnte tatsächlich das ganze auch als Backup-Internetleitung
benutzen, wenn Vodafone mal wieder Probleme haben sollte, das kommt ja 1-2 mal so im Quartal
vor, dass Vodafone für ein paar Stunden nicht geht, und dafür ist es ganz praktisch, aber
die haben kein Multisim, so, was ich jetzt bis jetzt gefunden hab, ist Telekom-Multisim,
aber Telekom, wir können das ja mit denen vergleichen, Telekom ist halt relativ teuer,
so, also nehmen wir mal, Multisim machen wir nur mal ein Multisim, so, Tarif, Tarif auswählen,
so, das ist schon mal richtig pepega gemacht bei der Telekom, also, das sieht ja so aus,
umso mehr Karten man da rein macht, umso billiger wird's, das ist aber Chebat, das stimmt überhaupt
nicht, das ist einfach nur die Karten, also das Geld durch die Kartenanzahl geteilt, was
aber Schwachsinn ist, weil das ja eigentlich überhaupt nichts mit dem normalen Anwendungsgebiet,
also mit dem Einsatzzweck zu tun hat, also wenn man sich das hier unten anguckt, normalerweise
kostet 39 und zwei Karten kosten dann einfach dann 54, also die Anzeige da oben ist total
pepega, also ich würde halt sowas hier machen und dann noch Multisim dabei nehmen, aber
es ist halt genau, es ist mir eigentlich zu teuer, das ist ja die Sache, guck mal, wenn
ich, Moment nicht mal, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich hab mich verklickt, ich hab mich
verklickt, Multisim, das will ich haben, so, und das ist halt abfuckteuer, guck mal, 40
Euro im Monat, ok, also was sagt der Chat, was soll ich mal ausprobieren, schau dir
mal Premiumsim an und was sonst noch, was würde sonst empfohlen, wie würde man ein
Handy einrichten, wenn man keinen WLAN hat und man braucht die eSIM um ins Internet zu
kommen, hä, wie würde man, genauso wie normales Handy, du kannst ja bei den meisten Handys
sogar eine SIM Karte einlegen und dann sagen, konvertiere mir die in eine eSIM, du kannst
eine SIM plus eine eSIM bestellen, das kann schon sein, das bringt dir aber nichts, wenn
du nicht beides gleichzeitig auf zwei verschiedenen Geräten benutzen kannst, doch das geht, das
geht, convert SIM to eSIM, ah guck, SIM Karte auf demselben iPhone in eine eSIM konvertieren,
wo ist.... wo ist die Musik?
so so spooky wie besser premium sim ok premium sim guck ich mir jetzt mal an premium sim
klingt schon klingt schon äußerst äußerst premium klingt das ganze
bei der telekom kann aber nur eine sim karte gleichzeitig sms empfangen ok
also zeigt mal her was haben die denn hier nur lte kein 5g was mache ich denn jetzt gegen
corona und mit bill gates also ich habe mit bill über twitter pn schon ausgemacht ich benutze
jetzt auch bald 5g was was ist das kann ich nicht einfach nur einfach nur lte benutzen
24 monat laufzeit ist auch nicht so geil aber schon in ordnung so also zeigt mal was haben
die denn hier 4gb lte monatlich kündbar bm ach bereiche ja die wollen nicht die wollen
nicht zu 24 monat laufzeit so kostet 50 m mit s mobil eigentlich vollkommen ok
ich finde das hier eigentlich gar nicht übel 9g reicht mir dicke 9g 799
und wo kann man multisim und so auswählen
60 für nur drei euren nein ach so da muss er mehr ausgeben als notwendig
multisim hier ok das ist tatsächlich preislich
multikart und multisim ist das gleiche
und man kann bis zu drei stück sich holen das ist tatsächlich relativ relativ günstig
und gibt es als auch als e sim prämium sim weiter stöbern
anscheinend
ja ok na das ist tatsächlich das ist tatsächlich nur option moment wir gucken
aber bewertung wie taugen die so heute stimmt übrigens nicht wir probieren
heute endeavor os aus was wir schon mal vor drei jahren oder so gemacht haben aber aber
aber frank hat keine hat keine multisim schlechter kundendienst teure pakete für stammkunden
prämium sind kein vertrauen sehr schlechte internetverbindung kann
er der anbieter wahrscheinlich wenig für wenn er wenn er irgendwie sonst am arsch der welt wohnt
das ist sass das eine ist trusted shops
also das ist komisch dass es hier 1,6 hat und da 4,91 da ist doch
irgendwas da ist die diskrepanz doch sehr groß dazwischen oder
verifizieren ja was auch immer das bedeuten soll trusted shops kenne ich trusted shops
ist eigentlich recht bekannt die gibt es ja auch schon ewig null das ist sehr so so so sie
ist das das stimmt doch was nicht 11 verifizierte bewertung moment es gibt nur 11 verifizierte
bewertung der rest ist das ist doch das ist doch fake also da stimmt doch irgendwas ganz
gewaltig netz helga es zeigt mal her elga es kräuterhaus sankt bernhardt also da stimmt
irgendwas warum kann man denn warum kann man denn nicht man kann anscheinend anscheinend
ja auch nicht sagen dass man nur also alle bewertung nicht nur verifizierte bewertung
haben will ne also da ist irgendwas ganz ganz das das das das das sieht mir doch schon
realistischer aus was da drin steht betrüger und hinterlistiges unternehmen filtern los
da ist für den sub anzeige wegen datemissbrauch anzeige ist raus also ganz ehrlich da bezahle
ich vielleicht doch lieber bei der telekom ein bisschen mehr die machen wirklich keinen
guten eindruck hier ich meine das ist ja vernichtend
ja es beschweren sich halt hauptsächlich die leute die scheiße finden aber bei der
telekom beschweren sich halt die leute über alles und nicht nur über mobilfunk gar kein
netboot oh ja wir können auch netboot machen leute da können wir mal unseren boot usb stick
testen das machen wir jetzt mal ich bin mir nicht sicher ob endeavor os in netboot dabei
ist probieren wir das doch mal aus also was wir uns heute mal angucken ist folgendes endeavor
os das ist ein arch linux flavor nennt man das glaube ich korrekterweise und was das auszeichnet
ist wohl dass es quasi ein klassisches arch linux ist allerdings mit einem einfachen installer
wobei ich sagen muss der normale arch linux installers arch linux setup ist mittlerweile
auch vollkommen ok und es bietet wohl relativ viel vorkonfigurierte desktop environments
das müssen wir uns jetzt müssen wir uns heute mal angucken die haben beispielsweise wo
steht ihr da und wo steht ihr was die eigentlich alles haben die haben i3 gibt es hier irgendwo
also man kann man kann dazwischen man kann das dazwischen switchen hier genau 7 desstops
desktop environments die gibt es die haben vorkonfigurierte xfce mate lxqt lxde ich dachte
eigentlich dass es mittlerweile zusammen was auch immer cinnamon plasma gnome bachi fluxbox
ne openbox i3 bspwm ok sway kommen nicht qtile und warm alles klar da lernen wir heute noch
ein paar neue sachen kennen wie lanus wie lanus ne wobei ich wollte ich wollte ja mit
meinem boot usb stick ausprobieren sekunde ist denn dort überhaupt endeavor os dabei
wo habe ich mein boot mein boot usb stick sackleute 512 g 512 g wo ist es ja hier ist er ok dann
legen wir mal eine vm an und gucken gucken uns das an new virtual machine kasse workstation
ich installiere later linux jawoll test so ja das kann auf kann ruhig auf c ist mir
egal ich lösche sein nachher eh wieder nammer auf processors 6 oder wir machen 1 und 6 kerne
dass es ordentlich flutscht 16 g ram wir haben ja genug das muss das wie gesagt das muss
ordentlich flutschen nat ist ok jawoll jawoll jawoll single file keine ahnung 200 gig test
kackel wunderbar customize hardware den printer machen wir raus den letzten lassen wir dran
usb stellen wir auf usb 3 1 weil sonst manchmal mit dem usb stick probleme gibt ok so ich
stöpsel mal mein boot usb stick rein normalerweise normalerweise würde ich würde ich ja einfach
das iso runterladen rein hängen gut ist aber wir gucken mal ob netboot ob netboot endeavor
os drinnen hat bin ich mal gespannt das muss man ausprobieren connect to host kackel starten
auf geht's ja ja ich habe finished install neustarten neustarten und von usb wir müssen
den usb stick nur mal dran hängen sandisk 3.1 warum geht das nicht kann das sein dass
es nicht geht weil es ein 3.1 stick ist jetzt connect to test kackel achso da ist also aus
irgendwelchen gründen kann ich meine kann ich mein usb stick hier mal hier geht das
schon mal interessant kann das sein dass das das phänomen hatte ich noch nicht dass man
usb sticks nicht mounten kann könnte das daran liegen weil ich es auf 3.1 umgestellt habe
ok dann werden wir nicht von usb booten sondern ich lade die iso runter keine ahnung was er
für schmerzen hat download latest release endeavor os casini neo 22 12 punkt iso wo
ist er ich sehe nicht leute wo ist der download ah hier you can download it hier art schilung
taiwan ja ganz wichtig da müssen wir das unbedingt von von shit hab wir laden es von
von von jithub unter geht auch relativ zackig wie schnell sind wir unterwegs im download
40 mb das saugt das saugt schnell gachibus welche desktop environment als erstes gucken
wir uns mal i3 an weil i3 ja das ist was ich hier normalerweise auch verwende mit wir brauchen
unbedingt den richtigen hintergrund sonst ist es nicht original und dann gucken wir uns
die anderen aber auch mal an gucken wie gut die sachen vor konfiguriert sind ihr wisst
ja ich mag eigentlich so gut wie keinen linux desktop außer außer also keine keine oberfläche
ich mag kein kde ich mag kein gnome und sonst was vielleicht werden wir uns ja heute können
wir uns ja heute eines besseren belehren lassen ist der download fertig sieht so aus downloads
wo hat er hin runter geladen ne der ist auch gar nicht fertig kannst du kurz erklären was
endeavor os ist ein art schlinux mit vor konfigurierten desktop environments und ein paar default
configs und einem einfacheren installer soweit ich das verstanden habe gucken wir doch mal
lassen wir uns doch mal von denen erklären warum man das verwenden sollte
a terminal centric distro with vibrant and friendly moment community die community ist
friendly da habe ich so meine zweifel die community ist eigentlich der regel nie friendly
ok mal kurz gucken ob die community wirklich freundliches ok anscheinend anscheinend schon
ja
ok die machen tatsächlich halbwegs freundlich eindruck ich bin immer skeptisch wenn die
sagen dass sie freundlich sind weil die meisten communities vor allem im linux umfeld sind
nicht wirklich freundlich das ist das macht ganz gut ok also endeavor os da haben wir
es zack auf geht's gut jetzt können wir installieren also ja vielleicht soll ich noch das cd laufwerk
verbinden und jetzt jetzt aber jawoll gut mal gespannt mal gespannt ob das ganze tools
mitbringt sodass ich gleich mein bildschirm ordentlich fullscreen habe endeavor os default
jawoll ansonsten kann ich kann es ja skalieren für die installation und falls es das nicht
mitbringen zu dem halt einfach das schlimmste forum leute ihr wisst was mein lieblings forum
ist was mit mit mit ganz vielen deppen drin oder ok es gibt zwei forren es gibt zwei forren
die richtig sacken eins davon ist das frinas forum oder ok heiße heiße ist anderweitig
dämlich das schlimmste forum was ich kenne ist das microcontroller forum guck mal die
haben vor immer tools dabei das macht schon mal einen sehr guten eindruck auf mich vor
immer tools vorinstalliert das microcontroller forum ist das größte shit forum allerzeit
eine olli dankeschön für den sub microcontroller forum so guck mal wir machen einfach mal irgendein
irgendein topic auf also erstens sieht dieses forum aus wie von 1995 und die leute sind
so unfreundlich ja das das geht ja jetzt ja noch das geht ja jetzt ja noch alles aber
das ist teilweise so viele deppen unterwegs das kann ich keinem empfehlen sich damit auseinander
zu setzen zumal ich da auch wenig hilfreiches also es gibt ja vielleicht die ein oder anderen
forum da sind die leute nervig aber du findest hilfreiche informationen für die paar fälle
wo ich wirklich mal suchen musste was irgendwie esp 32 sachen anging waren die noch nicht
mal hilfreich ok also so sieht das ganze standardmäßig aus ich muss sagen ich bin schon mal positiv
davon überrascht dass vor immer tools vorinstalliert sind hast du für windows elf eigentlich vor
immer workstation 17 gekauft ja ich habe auf dem anderen habe ich noch 15 glaube ich es
gibt es gibt probleme es gibt probleme mit windows elf leider leider es gibt probleme
mit windows das liegt nicht an vor immer workstation 17 die probleme hast du seit vor immer workstation
15.1 oder so was du hast zum beispiel massiven input lag in nilox vms wenn du was auf der
tastatur tippst und sowas die einzige möglichkeit um es wirklich gut zu betreiben ist hyper
wie auszuschalten du musst hyper wie ausschalten per kommando zeilen switch falls du es mal
installiert hat du musst hyper wie deaktivieren dann geht vor immer workstation 17 ohne probleme
das dumme ist halt wenn du hyper wie deinstallierst beziehungsweise deaktivierst kannst du kein
wsl mehr verwenden kein wsl 2 witzigerweise ging die gleiche kombi unter windows 10 ohne
probleme also frag mich bitte nicht was microsoft da wieder für komische dinger zusammen gewusstet
hat also wenn du probleme mit 16 hast hast du höchstwahrscheinlich auch probleme mit
17 probier 15.0 15.0 ist glaube ich die letzte version die keine probleme hatte mit input
lag und sowas mit aktiviertem hyper wie unter windows 11 mach hyper wie aus easy 17 allein
wird wahrscheinlich nix ändern wenn du probleme hast mit 16 war ganz aber du kannst ja einfach
für 3 euro 50 in key kaufen für vmw das ist nicht dass es in irgendeiner art und weise
feuerwehr jetzt mal ausprobieren ok also was ich schon mal sehr gut finde ist dass die
standardmäßig vm tools mitbringen was man hier dran erkennt dass es eben in der vm ordentlich
resized was haben wir hier am start was ist das für eine oberfläche cinnamon was meint
ihr was das ist ich habe keinen plan ich würde sagen cinnamon cinnamon cinnamon wie auch
immer was ist das ist das ist das cinnamon vor allem wo sieht man das wo könnte man
sehen was es ist das chat manch einer sagt xfc einer sagt kde neofetch stimmt können
wir gucken ob das standardmäßig drin ist xf es ist xfc es ist anscheinend xfc neofetch
neofetch standardmäßig auch schon dabei alles gut poggers endeavor os linux vmw und
es ist xfc xfc oder auch als ich noch überhaupt wobei ich weiß ja gar nicht ob das stimmt
aber als ich noch null plan davon hatte wie man das eventuell aussprechen könnte habe
ich das xfc genannt richtig xfc also quasi xfc sowas xfc wenn du entscheiden müsstest
kde oder gnom das ist eine schwierige entscheidung ich finde beides richtig kacke wahrscheinlich
kde wahrscheinlich noch am ersten kde wobei ich die default optik wahrscheinlich von gnom
besser finden würde weiß ich wie gesagt ich mag ich mag eigentlich gar keine linux desktops
und oberflächen am besten am besten dann tatsächlich noch mate oder xfc ok also das ist das live
system hier gibt es irgendwas spannendes zu sehen man hat einen aktuellen firefox dabei
der weise live system ist erst mal eine weile braucht man hat standardmäßig keine x tensions
dabei was ich auch ok finde gehört sich auch nicht blut shit vor zu installieren kde das
sind die gleichen leute die auch nicht ubuntu sagen sondern was haben wir hier unten endeavor
os lock tool was lock das share logs nein nein nein nein nein was den sinn von dem tool
verstehe ich nicht ist das wenn man hilfe braucht um im forum besser fragen zu können
hier die des lock tun tuner tuner ist poc tuner wie auch am start ich muss sagen optisch optisch
ich mag diese diesen das finde ich finde ich gut ich mag diese weltraum thematik irgendwie
das finde ich finde ich nice normalerweise mag ich diesen farbton eher weniger also ist
er fast schon ein bisschen lila aber das haben sie ganz schick gemacht das hat sich dieses
weltraum feeling und so finde ich ganz gut gibt es sehr ernsthaft jemand der diese funktion
bei fenstern benutzt reborn os desktop das kenne ich gar nicht zeigt mal wie das aussieht
reborn os desktop ich muss sagen welchen desktop ich tatsächlich ganz ok fand wenn man halt
ein komplettes desktop environment haben will ist diesen china chinesen desktop ich weiß
nicht wie er heißt der von deep in linux den fand ich tatsächlich ganz ganz brauchbar
weiß aber nicht wie das wie die oberfläche genau heißt
aber das war auch kde so dann würde ich sagen installieren wir das ganze mal bluetooth notes
aber gut ich will gerade bluetooth torya anschließend dran sorry os das haben wir glaube ich auch
mal ausprobiert das hat mir nicht gefallen display resolution was haben sie da dabei
macht doch eigentlich ein ganz gut durchdachten eindruck also zumindest im live system gut
dann installieren wir das ganze noch mal start installer gucken wir uns mal die arch linux
installer experience an was ja immer noch einige leute abschreckt wobei ich sagen muss
der letzte arch installer also dieses install script ist wirklich nicht schwierig zu bedienen
kann er bekommt eigentlich jeder hin online er will dann kann ich in der vm nicht benutzen
ready to take auf ok wir machen das erstmal fullscreen worden wir machen es nicht fullscreen
willkommen zu moment warum ist das auf deutsch egetz geh weg american english hell yeah das
einzige englisch was gilt american english gibt es auch gibt es auch uk english oder
so british british english die einzig echte sprache mit vor allem den einzig echten einheiten
wisst ihr wisst ihr was meine lieblings meine lieblings einheit ist meine lieblings bullshit
einheit habe ich glaube ich schon paar mal paar mal erzählt aber ich erzähle es euch
noch mal btu pro stunde beste btu british thermal unit ist definiert jetzt passt mal
auf ein btu ist definiert als die wärme energie die benötigt wird um ein britisches
von wasser um ein grad fahrenheit zu erwärmen also das ist wirklich best of bullshit woher
ich die einheit kenne normalerweise kann man sich fragen also hat das überhaupt irgendwie
eine relevanz ja bei usv bei bei unterbrechungs freien stromversorgungs kisten wird oftmals
der energieverbrauch in btu angegeben warum ich habe keine ahnung da steht es aber oftmals
als btu drauf also ok also 1000 1000 btu pro stunde sind ungefähr 293 watt alles klar
warum können die nicht einfach 293 watt schreiben anstatt 1000 btu pro stunde mit 293 watt kannst
du dir wenigstens was vorstellen naja dann solltest du einfach in joules pro sekunde
oder pro punkt was auch immer angeben oder halt in watt aber muss es allen ernstes btu
sein ok weiter im text ich habe keine ahnung warum die das machen weil bei usv ist das
geliebt ok wir machen jetzt britisch englisch europe berlin dieser installer ich weiß nicht
welcher installer das ist den habe ich aber in dieser art und weise schon seit den letzten
20 jahren linux installation immer wieder gesehen diese karte mit dem anklicken das
kalama also jedes also ich habe so oft gesehen die letzten 20 jahre über genau diese karte
mit diesem und dieser auswahl das immer kalamares war das oder bundo gibt es auch so was ok
berlin alles gut keyboard ok das nicht auf englisch sondern auf german und zwar bitte
schön german no dead no dead keys ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich finde es immer noch
blödsinnig dass no dead keys nicht der default ist wer sich jetzt fragt was no dead keys
bedeutet guckt mal neben die eins auf eurer tastatur da habt ihr dieses zeichen oben dieses
dieses hütchen da ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das das zirkum flex ist oder das der kringel
das zirkum flex ist so und wenn ihr ein das nur einmal machen wollt dann geht das nicht
ihr drückt den knopf einmal und dann noch mal das ist das ist ein dead key weil er nicht
beim direkt beim ersten mal was macht ja du kannst es gibt da gibt verschiedene varianten
also bei mir bei mir geht das mit lehrtaste zum beispiel nicht du musst ja doch du musst
den einzeln also es ist doof deswegen das sind das sind dead keys und wenn man dead keys
ausschaltet dann ist einfacher druck seht ihr eindruck schon dieses ding und ich sehe
nicht ein warum ich dead keys brauche ich war immer no dead keys endless possibilities
ok kann man einfach auch mehrere sachen auswählen dass ich einfach alles haben nee ok jetzt
ok dann machen wir an der stelle mal nur für den fall der fälle dass man es nicht nach
installieren kann mal einen snapshot dass ich vielleicht den anderen krempel dann gleich
installieren kann wo kann man das einstellen unter windup ja unter windows kein plastenschimmer
ok leute mit was wie i3 wir fangen mit i3 an easy i3 was sonst da kann man nämlich den
direkten vergleich machen unter linux ja in deiner tastatur verwaltungsding von deinem
environment oder du kannst laut keys verwenden auf dem terminal und was es sonst noch so
alles gibt snapshot haben wir gemacht da kann man nämlich das i3 gleich mit meinem i3 mal
vergleichen also ich kann nicht mehr rauswählen könnt ihr einen live image empfehlen dass
man sich auf den usb stick ziehen kann ich habe dass ich das mir unter art das letzte
in video abteil live image ja also ich habe ich habe mir erst letztens in usb stick usb
stick gemacht mit sowas du kannst zum beispiel also wenn du wenn du irgendwas haben willst
was einfach geht nehmen die gepartet die gepartet cd oder system rescue cd oder irgendein aktuelles
ubuntu oder du kannst auch einfach tales verwenden in ich teils kali verwenden zum beispiel nicht
teils kali linux ist auch wunderbar als life system kann es eigentlich nehmen was du willst
ich habe mich letztes bisschen umgeguckt macht eigentlich gar nicht so großunterschied oder
du nimmst netboot netboot ist auch gut weil über netboot kannst du alle weiteren distributionen
aus dem internet nachladen und live live cds starten live usb starten
ok weiter also aktuell kann ich nicht mehr als ein desktop auswählen aber wahrscheinlich
später erst wir nehmen kde nicht kde 3 und nicht kde soll ich sagen ach hier kann man
jetzt mehr installieren ok easy ja leute dann machen wir das doch mal kde
hier wird das kommt was was erzählen
leute wir machen zwar doch nicht mit kde wir gehen zurück zum installer weil zumindest
zumindest für die ersten paar weil ich will wissen wie das wie das aussieht ohne dass
das gesamte menü mit zigtausend programm vollgemüllt wird weil die meisten leute werden
realistisch betrachtet ein desktop environment oder maximal zwei desktop environments drauf
hauen bei sich
die drei firefox gibt cpu specific microcode updates ich mag das wenn mein rechner anfällig
ist gegenüber meltdown und specter und sowas das muss so sein
e-speak drucker printing support ok lass mal einfach so next bootloader no bootloader
ok das ist unsinnig
group nicht system debut der klassiker gibt's hier group group next partitions erase
manual partitioning ok jetzt müssen wir mal was ausprobieren
ich will gucken ob das unterstützt dass man sein system verschlüsselt installieren kann
da bin ich mal gespannt die meisten installer tun sich ein bisschen
bisschen schwer damit
manually partition
wieso fehlt bei dir system debut
ah wisst ihr woran das liegen kann
ich glaube ich habe nicht uefi gebootet ich glaube wir müssen noch mal kurz booten
ähm leute ich boote system debutscheiße warum
finde das eigentlich ganz praktisch das geht schneller meistens als grube
unabhängig davon ob wir das machen
jetzt für schmerzen ich habe einen snapshot von nicht installierten system gezogen man
wir stellen wir stellen es noch mal um auf uefi boot
wir haben ja nichts gemacht die zwei dialoge könnte ich auch noch mal
kann ich auch noch mal durchklicken jetzt
was passiert eigentlich jetzt
wenn ich jetzt auf den snapshot zurückgehe hier habe ich per bios gebootet und jetzt
per uefi der kackt doch ab wenn ich wenn ich das
dann doch da bestimmt irgendwelche probleme ok start installer online
ok also was hatten wir ausgewählt britisch britisch englisch location berlin keyboard
german no dead key
beste so i3 jo passt
so dann machen wir doch an der stelle jetzt noch mal einen snapshot
snapshot take snapshot und dann gehen wir in snapshot
weil ansonsten wird das müll das die platte voll und das muss ja nicht sein
löschen den ersten snapshot weil er geht eh nicht mehr
ist das deine katze im bild ja und das hier auch
das aber eine andere
wo ist eigentlich wo ist eigentlich die alle ja hier habe ich auch noch eine das ist auch
noch eine
das ist nicht meine
i put a snapshot in your snapshot to snapshotting while snapshot
so jetzt haben wir den krempel hier next
aha ok also leute man muss man muss uefi booten
dass man system deboot als auswahl hat willst du auf ein neues us umsteigen für deine
form ne ich will ich nicht ich habe doch erst ich habe doch erst hier neu
eingerechnet neu installiert ich habe das jetzt genauso konfiguriert wie ich
das haben will das bleibt so ich bin ja gar nicht mein team axel
das bleibt so andere sachen angucken system deboot jetzt ist no swap
ja wir haben 16 g swap no hibernate wunderbar
jetzt ist die frage kann man gut dass wir einen snapshot gemacht haben kann man an der
stelle jetzt verschlüsselung auswählen oder nicht ach hier ein cryptos gab es das
leute habt ihr das vorher gesehen gab es das vorher auch schon oder gab es auch nur bei
uefi ganz das bei der anderen installation auch
schon und ich habe es einfach nur nicht gesehen
warum warum nutzt du nicht linux bare metal auf deinem hauptrechner weil ich
genug sachen mache die ich besser unter windows machen kann und es lässt sich
linux unter windows einfacher virtualisieren als windows unter linux
kann ich im chat ein link senden du kannst ein link senden allerdings je
nachdem was das für ein link ist kannst du danach vielleicht nie wieder link
senden ich weiß ja nicht was du vor hast du posten wenn es was harmloses ist
dann ist kein problem ok das ist was harmloses
bett bett pepo wir haben übrigens ein eigenes also gar ein eigenes pet emote
noch mal glück gehabt ja
das ist das ist subscriber only kz fbs streicheln dürfen nur subscriber
nur subscriber und die auch
also passphrase leute six hat passwort da kommt ihr nie drauf wer redet mein
passwort falsch richtig 1 2 3 4 5 6
es wurde mal ein email postfach von mir gehackt vor 20 jahren oder so und
wisst ihr was ich dafür den passwort hatte ich glaube das wisst ihr weil ich
habe das schon mal in dem video erzählt also die leute das video gesehen haben
wenn es wahrscheinlich wissen ich hatte das passwort katze 1 2 3
richtig high q passwort top secret ok 1 2 3 4 5 6
encrypted system next also moment swap die heiberne
hibernator wollen wir nicht hibernator ist quasi das was ich glaube
ruhe modus auf deutsch unter windows heißt next full name
akum ich wollte jetzt irgendjemand aus dem chat nehmen aber dann regen sich die
anderen im chat auf dass ich nicht ihr name genommen habe das kann ja durchaus
passieren deswegen machen wir was neutrales so und es kommt max vmw 201
perfekter perfekter name ich wusste dass irgendwie so was so
choose passwort 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
kommt keiner drauf log in automatically nähe nähe next
next ist gut eine fett partition zum booten
das war es anscheinend install install now sollte schnell gehen wir gucken mal
wie gut man dann desktop umgebung nach installieren kann im laufenden betrieb
es kann ja nicht sein dass ich immer den installer ausführen muss dafür was
jetzt also leichte transparenz wenn das fenster inaktiv ist ok batschi wir
müssten mal batschi ausprobieren habe ich glaube ich noch nie noch nie benutzt
taugt das batschi desktop
und und auf welcher basis ist das bestimmt bestimmt auch in den cute
verschnitt oder gtk oder sowas ist ja im prinzip immer nur cute oder gtk als
ui frabe außer 17 jahre was eigenes was mit ihnen los ist chat weiß jemand von
euch ob ich mit diesem regex moment alter was ja was willst du matchen du kannst
du kannst es es kämen du musst aber in dem regex normalerweise quals nicht
es kämen du musst quals nur es kämen wenn uns
bei krebs verwendet zum beispiel weil die schelders vorher sonst interpretiert
oder weil es string ist in deiner programmiersprache also regex selbst
hat gar keine probleme mit quals kommt auf die kam auf die programmiersprache
an welche programmiersprache und was willst du
matchen installing 167 packages aber wir toggeln mal das loge
yay und woher weiß ich jetzt ob er was macht aber da steht was er macht
haben die irgendwie einen super langsam miror benutzt kann das sein dass sie
irgendwie den miror haben der abfahrende wobei ne geht eigentlich geht
ist schon mehr oder weniger alles durch echt jetzt habe ich noch nie gehört
miror aus nordkorea schien schiener chinesen miror ja endlich sagt es mal
jemand ich wusste ich wüsste gar nicht sonst wie man packages gescheit
managed damit ruby ruby hat eine super advanced regex engine in ruby ich habe
schon eine weile ruby nicht mehr gemacht aber ich glaube in ruby sind strings
tatsächlich double quads allerdings hat ruby mehrere varianten wie man strings
schreiben kann ja also wenn du wenn du wenn du die in
double quads machst dann musst du einmal in backslash vor dein vor dein
quads machen oder hat der ruby oder hat der ruby für regex eine eigene
syntax dass du gar keine quads machen musst
verbotene emotes
alles klar das ist aber kein regex das ist string ruby string replace das
willst du so wahrscheinlich nicht verwenden
ach doch das ist ein regex das ist ein regex es ist einmal ruby ruby hat
tatsächlich kann ich mich gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern moment moment
moment moment das funktioniert nicht das funktioniert aus dem grund nicht ich
bin mir relativ relativ sicher nicht hundertprozentig sicher aber ich bin
mir relativ sicher dass du mit dass das du dass du oder dass du das klammern
musst dass es funktioniert
ich glaube du musst das klammern das oder geht aber das sollte tatsächlich so
funktionieren an der stelle sieht erst mal sieht eigentlich erst mal ganz
zinnig aus wir probieren das wir probieren das einfach mal wir probieren
das jetzt mal aus weil ich habe ich habe wirklich lange kein ruby mehr gemacht
auf fack wie heißt er diese ruby konsole noch mal freine er b gab es und er b
ruby alternativ wie ist die gute davon
fack man ich habe so lang kein ruby mehr gemacht auch wenn ist doch prei doch
prider also wie das aussieht schon ruby bray genau ich habe wirklich ich habe so
lang kein ruby mehr gemacht man ok sekunde es war jetzt bevor wir uns ein
devos weiter angucken der installiert ja der installiert ja ok all dann gleich
also ruby ruby stellst also was was willst du machen blub gleich kacke und
da drin sind quads oder wie putz blub ne moment
putz
was willst du jetzt machen blub punkt g sub und an regex regex stels ok alles
ersetzen durch nichts ok das schon mal klar jedes einser zeichen so was in der
richtung willst du noch machen oder und jetzt willst du quasi ein quad durch
nichts ersetzen es geht auch genauso du musst da überhaupt nichts du musst da
überhaupt nichts es käpen so was will ich bei passen ok da kann ich mir jetzt
nichts runter vorstellen was was was du mit das will ich bei
passen meinst so und das hier funktioniert soweit ich weiß auch gar
nicht doch ich dachte ich hätte ich hätte wetten können das muss man
klammern muss man anscheinend nicht klammern ok ja also an der stelle
sieht es jetzt nicht noch nicht so kompliziert aus restart now next
hallo
dann ok die buttons sind pepega leute woher soll ich erkennen dass die buttons
nicht gehen aber die gehen aber der geht
dann machen wir die cd wieder weg disconnect endeavor ok wir helfen wir
helfen dem dem amazon mal wobei ich immer noch nicht verstanden habe was du
genau machen willst ich will einen punkt oder ein double
quads durch kriegen ohne dass es gematcht wird wenn du wenn du es durch
kriegen willst ohne dass es gematcht wird dann schreib halt einfach in den
regex nicht das zeichen rein wird gem
also muss ok du musst ein ordentliches beispiel posten weil ich kann mir immer
noch nichts runter vorstellen was du eigentlich machen willst schrei machen
mal ein beispiel string und sag was da rauskommen soll schick mal ein
beispiel string weil ich kann mir da wirklich gerade wenig
drunter vorstellen was ist jetzt ist kaputt ach nee full disk encryption
genau erwartet input und erwartet output ja genau das kannst du das kannst du
machen kannst du mal machen da können wir mal schauen
please enter passphrase 123 456 ok full disk encryption schon mal nice dass es
nicht irgendwie diese login heimatverzeichnis verschlüsselung ist
wirklich komplette komplette disk per lux
ups jetzt ab ist ich kann ich hab mich verdrückt ok
hier kann man die desktops auswählen ok nice
ganz gut ganz gut ganz gut
ok so sieht also der von denen vorkonfigurierte id
firefox ist autostart in each login ja juckt mich ehrlich gesagt nicht will ich eh haben
ok wir gucken uns gleich mal die hilfeseite an
schon mal interessant
die tabs hat er umgedreht guckt mal die haben das terminal tab
direkt was haben die für den terminal was was liefern die von terminal mit
was ist das xf ce terminal ok das mag ich schon mal gar nicht
xf ce terminal hatte jetzt eigentlich geschrieben was er
nee aber nicht
welches terminal benutzt du in meiner wand manjarow vor ich habe keine manjarow
vor mir manjarow leute out aber nicht mehr kein manjarow wir haben echtes arch
linux by the way mittlerweile wir sind keine manjarow enjoyers mehr wir sind
echte arch enjoyers mittlerweile
wann gentoo oder oder vielleicht auch gentoo wenn ich bock drauf hab das
könnte man aber wirklich
leute wollen wir irgendwann mal einen gentoo installieren
nicht gentoo gentoo hab ich noch nie gemacht ich hab kein plan davon wie das funktioniert
linux vom scratch ist ja keine distro das ist eher ein tutorial wie baue ich mein ganzes
zeug selbst zusammen
wuppler os nee wuppler os würde bei mir wahrscheinlich gemp os heißen oder so
ok moment wir bekommen jetzt erklärt was er matchen wird also der input ist script
oh moment du willst du willst du willst xml passen mit regex also du kannst es in einfachen
fällen natürlich machen ich glaube da hast du viel mehr problemen
wenn du xml anfängst mit regex zu passen das geht nach hinten los
das heißt sagen wir der input ist script dings werden gematcht und es kommt script raus
ja ok das ist kein problem das noch noch kein problem
ich würde mich aber ernsthaft überlegen xml mit mit regex zu passen also wirklich
seriously das kann nur abfuck werden hat ruby nicht sogar ein xml pass in der standard
lib drinnen aber gut weil du bist ja bist ja schon ein
grund haben ich will jetzt nicht ich will jetzt nicht den den reddit oder forums typ
raushängen lassen der der erzählt du willst dass du sollst das nicht machen also kannst
natürlich machen wie du willst also du willst jetzt wissen regex dafür wie man script testet
oder was wie man script raus pass ich versuche das zu bypassen ich check immer noch nicht
was willst du bypassen du willst ok chat ich muss ich muss mir das jetzt erst mal checken
was er will also du hast quasi du hast quasi den input string so was hier ja ok und du
willst damit was machen du willst du willst quasi du willst quasi so was hier machen
hier ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
ok ok ok okidgo Chengou Idee ist so universes
Boah, das weiß ich auch noch gar nicht.
Ach, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Jetzt, okay, jetzt hab ich's verstanden, was er will.
Ich hab's verstanden, was du willst.
Das ist eine Aufgabe.
Du sollst einen Input-String finden, der durch den Regex geht.
Oder?
Das willst du.
Du sollst einen Input-String finden, der nicht vom Regex erfasst wird.
Sag das doch.
Okay, also hier, Moment.
Okay, das probieren.
Wo hast du das denn gepostet?
Alter, das ist auch schon mal geil, Alter.
Also, du suchst quasi einen, ähm, du suchst quasi einen Input-String, also sowas hier,
keine Ahnung.
So, du suchst jetzt was, wo nicht, wo das hier durchgeht, oder wie?
Nee, da bringt dir, da bringt dir Escape nix.
Und nachdem das hier einzelne Zeichen sind, wird dir jedes Zeichen davon, äh, wird dir
jedes Zeichen davon matchen.
Ich mein, du, ich mein, dir steht natürlich frei, dass du andere Zeichen verwendest, das
bringt dir aber wahrscheinlich nix.
Du könntest eventuell UTF-8-Magic machen, ja, das, das geht, also wenn du Emojis da
reinschreibst zum Beispiel, das sollte, das sollte ja funktionieren, wenn man das jetzt
doch richtig macht.
Du könntest das, du könntest das all encoden, aber nachdem ich ja nicht weiß, was auf der
anderen Seite diesen Kram dann verarbeitet, bringt das, bringt das ja eigentlich auch gar
nix, also es ist immer noch zu unspezifisch, was, was es jetzt eigentlich bezwecken soll.
Also mach, mach doch mal ein Beispiel Input und ein Beispiel Output, also ich kann's mir
immer noch nicht wenig, wenig darunter vorstellen.
Ich mein, einfach Quotes reinmachen bringt dir ja nix, die werden ja auf jeden Fall,
die werden ja auf jeden Fall ersetzt und die Quotes escapen bringt dir, bringt dir im Endeffekt
auch nix.
Wobei das hier in dem String ist, selbst, selbst wenn du's doppelt eskapsst, das ist,
das bringt dir, bringt dir auch nix, weil du kannst UTF-8-Magic probieren, ob du da irgendwas
findest, was, was durchgeht und so aussieht wie ein Quote, du kannst es all encode, aber
selbst, selbst das bringt dir an der Stelle nix.
Ne, die Quotes kriegst du da nicht durch, die Quotes kriegst du nicht durch, ich mein,
der matcht jeden einzelnen Character, was übrigens auch mega ineffizient ist und guckt
ob's ein Quote ist, egal wie du das Quote schreibst, kriegst du das nicht durch.
Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst quasi sagen, was weiß ich, Unicode-Character-looks-like-double-Quote,
ich weiß nicht, ob man das überhaupt so in Google suchen kann, ok, sowas hier kannst
du wahrscheinlich machen und das funktioniert, ich mein, das ist dann aber kein richtig echtes
Double-Quote und es wird, es wird halt auch nicht richtig funktionieren, ich mein, was
du machen kannst ist, also was du machen kannst, wenn dein Ziel ist, es durch den Regex zu
bekommen und es am Ende dann wieder zurück zu konvertieren, du kannst das Base64 encode
da durchschicken und dann wieder decode, das funktioniert, wenn du es einfach nur willst,
dass es quasi fehlerfrei durch den Regex durchgeht, dann kannst du Base64 encode, das funktioniert.
Ah, also du kannst zum Beispiel hergehen und sagen, Echo, machen wir das jetzt mal, äh,
hier, Script, Base64, das geht, aber ansonsten, ok, dann, wie gesagt, das ist immer noch zu
unspezifisch, aber da fällt mir jetzt nichts scheiß ein zu.
Ok, gehen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache zurück, wir wollen uns ja eigentlich Endeavor OS angucken.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, also falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, Leute, sagt Bescheid.
Gut, gucken wir uns mal Endeavor OS an, also was haben wir hier standardmäßig zu bieten?
Was ich schon mal interessant finde, dass die den Firefox als erstes, allerwichtigste Dark
Reader, ohne Dark Reader geht hier nix, exzellent, gleich schon viel besser.
Ja, gleich schon viel, viel schicker, ich sehe, sie haben i3 mit Gaps, was ich, oh,
sie haben was, was ich nicht mag in i3, sie haben Anwendungsgruppierungen pro Desktop oder
pro Workspace, guckt, wenn ich jetzt auf dem zweiten Desktop bin und ich mache einen Terminal
auf, dann macht es das Terminal automatisch auf dem ersten Workspace auf und switcht mich
auf den zweiten, auf den ersten Workspace rüber, das mag ich nicht.
Wir gucken uns mal die i3-Config von denen an, was sie da standardmäßig gemacht haben.
Achso, ja, wie das Terminal heißt, hat mich jemand gefragt, habe ich ganz vergessen.
Das hier, das ist Westterm, heißt das und Westterm, also GitHub Westterm, ist ein mega
nice Terminal, habe ich erst vor ein paar Wochen entdeckt, aber ganz, ganz gute Bewertung.
Du kannst damit Tabs machen, so wie man das kennt, Tabs machen, kannst Splits machen,
wie in T-Max, ohne dass du T-Max brauchst, es ist relativ schnell, es hat, es hat Emoji,
Emoji Support.
Du weißt noch, als wir das Wetterdings durch T-Max, Moment, Wetter, Wetter, natürlich,
es kann Bilder anzeigen, Achtung, irgendwann, demnächst, Wetter Vorschau, es ist ein Terminal,
was tatsächlich richtig guten Image Support hat, du kannst zum Beispiel Image Cat, du
hast sogar GIF Animations Support im Terminal, was extrem sproggers ist, mir fällt zwar
kein realistisches Anwendungsszenario ein, wo man das öfters brauchen würde, aber wenn
man es braucht, ist es nice und eigentlich fast das beste an diesem Terminal, du hast
die Möglichkeit, es ganz normal zu konfigurieren, mit ein paar Konfig-Parametern, aber die gesamte
Konfiguration ist gültiges Lua, das heißt, man kann auch eigene Funktionen in der Konfig
entwickeln fürs Terminal, ja, zum Beispiel, wie meine rechte Maustaste funktioniert.
Ich habe meine rechte Maustaste nämlich so eingestellt im Terminal, dass wenn ich was
markiert habe, drücke die rechte Maustaste, dann geht es in die Zwischenablage, guck,
ich zeige euch mal meinen Clipboard-Manager, da ist es jetzt drin, Computer Science 1 PDF
und wenn ich dann nochmal die rechte Maustaste klicke, dann pastet er, allerdings nur wenn
sonst nicht selectet ist, also zum Beispiel, ich selecte das hier, drücke die rechte Maustaste
und selecte dann was anderes und drücke nochmal die rechte Maustaste, dann selectet er nur
weiter, erst wenn nichts mehr selectet ist und ich die rechte Maustaste drücke, dann
pastet er. Das sind so Sachen, das ist nicht das Default-Verhalten von dem Terminal, aber
das habe ich hiermit quasi selbst eingestellt. Sieht man ja auch hier, guckt, der guckt,
ist irgendwas markiert mit der Maus, hat es eine Selection, wenn ja, dann die Selection
in die Zwischenablage kopieren und die Selection clearen, wenn nicht, dann pasten und so kann
ich jetzt mit der rechten Maustaste, Zwischenablage einfügen machen. Mittlere Maustaste und so
geht natürlich immer noch, finde ich aber, ist eine coole Sache. Also, dass es eine vollwertige,
vollständige Lua-Umgebung ist, deine Config ist schon nice. Das einzige, was an Lua sackt,
ist, dass Arrays nicht bei Null anfangen. Ja, und mit Image Support kannst du wirklich
auch so Sachen wie Wetterbericht im Terminal machen. Ja, weißt du, 12 Grad und hier hast
jetzt Wettervorhersage, also du hast aber auch 32 Bit Color Support und alles. Also
das Terminal ist wirklich nice, hat bestimmt noch ein paar Features, an die ich jetzt nicht
gedacht habe, aber für mich aktuell, das mit Abstand beste Terminal, was es für Linux
gibt, aber Moment, was heißt für Linux? Das ist ja sogar Cross-Plattform, das gibt
es ja auch für Windows und für Mac, weil man unter Mac auch iTerm oder sowas verhindern
kann, aber das gibt es auch für Windows und Mac. So, gehen wir mal hier weiter. Also das
ist eine Sache, die mir schon mal nicht so gut gefällt. Sind das meine Koordinaten
gewesen da unten? Ja klar, hier, da wohne ich, eindeutig, hier, da, Darmstadt. Welches Terminal
war so gut? West Term, West Term. Das einzig dumme an West Term ist, die Default-Settings
sind ein bisschen kacke. Der Rest ist sehr nice. Ja, das habe ich auch ausprobiert, Sly,
ich finde West Term viel angenehmer, gerade weil du eben Panels splitten kannst und sowas,
du brauchst kein TMUX mehr. Und es ist nicht so Anti-TMUX wie Kitty, sodass du es trotzdem
gescheit verwenden kannst, wenn man das, wenn man das dann braucht. Ich habe sie nicht
mal mehr installiert mittlerweile. Und Blazingly Fast Written in Rust natürlich. Ja, aber
jetzt kommen wir mal zurück zu Endeavor OS. Ich muss sagen, eine Sache, die mir schon
mal gar nicht in der Standard-I3-Config gefällt. Okay, ordentliche, ordentliche Fontauswahl
haben sie auf jeden Fall schon mal, kann man nichts sagen. Ordentliche Fontauswahl, optisch,
optisch auch durchaus in Ordnung alles. Soweit okay. Was haben wir denn für den Vim? Vim?
Wie? MonkaS? Nano? Was ist da los? Was ist das hier schon mal? Nano hat er, aber kein
Vim. Also, und das wird ein ordentliches Archlinux sein, man. Archlinux ist Hackerman OS. Nano,
Alter. Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es einen Vim hat? Nee. Eieieieiei. Das geht aber nicht.
Was? Shift ZZ, wissen die wenigsten. Hast du dann Sessions, wenn man kein T-Max verbraucht?
Ja, du hast die Möglichkeit, dass du es irgendwie klein servermäßig laufen lässt, das Terminal,
habe ich aber nicht eingerichtet. Okay, wie würde man jetzt hier offiziell Vim nachentzeln?
Update Mirrors, okay, machen wir mal. Was? Ach, das ist für Pac-Man-Mirror quasi ein
Frontend. Okay, okay, okay, kann man machen. Hätte man jetzt nicht unbedingt gebraucht,
ehrlich gesagt, aber okay. Und wenn die haben eigene, die haben eigene Mirrors. Okay, also
sprich, die machen nicht den Manjaro-Shit mit eigenen Mirrors, oder? Das ist wahrscheinlich
nur für ihre Custom Software. Update System, können wir auch mal machen. There is nothing
to update, ja, gut. Package Cleanup. Ich teste einfach, was die Dinger machen. Quatsch,
scheiß drauf. Configure EOS Update Notifier. Mensch, nervt mich nicht. Change Display Manager.
GDM, LightDM, LX, juckt mich auch überhaupt nicht. Wallpaper. Und jetzt? Ach so, choose
one of wallpaper. Was ist das? Ist das Nautilus, oder? Was ist das für ein komischer? Ähm,
der Wallpaper gibt's net. Super. Download more wallpapers, das allerwichtigste. Wallpapers.
Was ist der Standard-Package? Es muss Pac-Man sein. Und Pac-Man und Yay. Das verstehe ich
nicht. Warum klont das jetzt Wallpapers? Warum kommt das nicht als Package einfach
über denen ihre Sachen mit? Ok, das ist schon mal ein bisschen weird-champig. Aber es ist
jetzt ja ähnlich, als bräuchte ich super viele Wallpapers. Classic. Na super. Wir haben
eine Wallpaper-Vorschau, die... Und PC Speaker ist an. Wir haben Wallpaper-Selector, der
nicht mal Vorschau anzeigt. Ok, das ist ja so sehr rudimentär, alles gemacht. Das brauchen
wir, das brauchen wir nicht. After install. Ok, update systems, haben wir alles schon
gemacht. General info assist, add more apps. Was macht das? What the fuck? Seriously? Ich
weiß schon wieder, warum ich die meisten Oberflächen nicht mag. Das ist mir schon wieder viel zu
viel UI-Rumgeklicker. Das ist unter anderem der Grund, warum ich E3 verwende. Auch wenn
das hier E3 ist, den ganzen Krempel braucht auch keiner. Wie macht man das hier übrigens?
Ah, Q. Hab ich bei mir ein bisschen anders gelegt. Ok, don't show me anymore. Weg. I
remember. I remember. Ich promise zu membern. Ne, das war ja nix. So, also was haben wir
hier unten für eine... Also die E3-Config an sich macht erstmal einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Was ich nicht mag ist, wie gesagt, dieses Switchen auf den anderen Desktop. Wim-Punkt...
Ah, Moment, Moment. Erstmal ein Wim installieren. Warum soll ich alle Wallpaper angucken? Wäre
ein besseres Wunder, als das Wallpaper anzugucken. Was ist das? Das glaube ich gar nicht mal,
die default. Ok, config, E3, E3-Config. Sieht alles relativ starr aus. Ok, Gaps. Gaps fast
schon ein bisschen zu viel für meinen Geschmack. Ich habe ja auch Gaps bei mir konfiguriert,
aber es gibt deutlich, ich zeige es mal, deutlich dezentere Gaps. Candy Endeavor E3-Config Emojis.
Du meinst im Terminal? Das werden wir gleich mal ausprobieren. Haben wir einen Launcher?
Ah, das ist... Das könnte Rofi sein oder auch nicht. Man weiß es nicht. Müssen wir
gleich mal gucken. Testen wir mal, ob das... Also übrigens kein GTK da... Alter, mehr
Werbung, please, man. What the fuck? Wollt ihr mich ver... Ok, jetzt kann man die Seite
wenigstens benutzen. Nein, Alter, das ist schlecht. WeirdChamp, ein Terminal, was keinen Emoji-Support
hat. Cringe in 2023, das geht aber nicht. Vielleicht kann es das Terminal auch und die
Schrift kann es nicht. Tweemoji. Ich muss mal kurz abgucken, wie der richtige Emoji-Font
heißt, den wir installieren müssen. Tweemoji? TTF-Tweemoji müssen wir installieren, ok.
Schauen wir mal, ob das was bringt oder ob das einfach nur Brocken ist. Natürlich Priorities.
Ok, es lag am fehlenden Font. Äh, was ist das für eine Schelle? Bash. Ah, sehr rudimentär
hier alles. Ok, also zumindest kann es Terminal Emojis, wenn man Emoji-Font installiert hat.
Das ist auch schon mal nicht verkehrt. Immerhin, immerhin. Wirklich, wirklich happy bin ich
mit dem Terminal, aber so in der Default-Konfig nicht. Optisch nicht so hübsch und der Rest,
ja weiß, weiß auch nicht. Ist irgendwie, ja nicht so wahnsinnig toll. Was haben wir denn
sonst noch? Was ist das hier unten? Ich wollte ja mal die Konfig mir angucken, was die da
noch haben und vielleicht auch wissen, was die benutzen. Ok, Windows Floating ist genau
das gleiche, Workspace Switchen. Wir haben Workspace für Terminal, Browser, File Explorer,
E-Mails und so Zeug wahrscheinlich, Instant Messaging und das war's. Ja, ist ganz gut
vorkonfiguriert. Ich persönlich hab eigentlich immer nur drei Workspaces, nämlich, gleich
mal das mal. Moment, die benutzen i3-Gaps noch? Oder die benutzen schon den richtigen
i3. Jaja, machen sie auch. Ich hab Workspaces ja eigentlich nur drei Stück vorkonfiguriert.
Browser, Terminal, Editor, fertig. Mehr Workspaces brauche ich nicht und wenn ich sie brauche,
kann ich ja hier immer noch durchswitchen. Ja, ich weiß, das ist jetzt gemerged mit den
Gaps, aber es steht dann explizit noch Gaps drinne hier. Ok, sie haben es schon mal gut
gemacht, dass Wim sich merkt, wo man aus der Datei rausgegangen ist. Find ich schon mal
ganz praktisch. Ok, Standardzeug. Screen Lock? Ok, probieren wir mal aus. Screen Lock. Oh.
Leute, hört ihr mich wieder? Ich hab grad mein Windows-Screen gelockt. Es war keine
gute Idee, Windows-Taste und L zu drücken. Ok, so sieht aber anscheinend der Log-Screen.
Oh, der ist hässlich, der Log-Screen, Alter. Du streamst doch immer von einer VM aus,
ist das jetzt VM in VM? Nein, ist es nicht. Ich streame nicht von einer VM aus. Ich streame
ganz normal von OBS in Windows aus und ich streame davon zwar meine VM, aber ich streame
nicht aus einer VM. Ok, es ist Rofi anscheinend. F1. Ach. Ok, das ist tatsächlich eine ganz
gute Idee. So ein Cheat-Cheat, wo man abgucken kann, wie die Tasten-Combi sind. Ja, ok,
das finde ich auch auf F1 ganz sinnvoll. Brightness Up, Brightness Down, brauche ich nicht. Fokus
soll ich benutzt haben. Was ich jetzt noch nicht gefunden habe ist, was denn jetzt Mod-Taste
mit D macht. Also ist das hier D-Menü, ist das Rofi, was ist das? App-Shortcuts, man
kann einen Browser öffnen, das brauche ich nicht auf einen Shortcut. Man kann einen Dateimanager
öffnen, ja, brauchen wir anders. Mod-Shift-Power-Profile, das ist ganz cool, brauche ich zwar nicht,
aber finde ich nice, dass ihr an sowas gedacht habt. Workspaces. Ja, das hier mag ich zum
Beispiel nicht. Das mag ich nicht, dass verschiedene, dass die Programme an den gleichen Workspace
gebunden sind. Ja, ihr seht es ja. Ich mache hier einen Terminant auf und es geht auf das
erste. Das ist ein Verhalten, das mag ich nicht, das würde ich wahrscheinlich raus
machen. Telegram, blöd. Transparency, ja, das machen wir. Ey, machen wir nicht. Also
die E3 Vorkonfiguration ist okay, aber ehrlich gesagt gefällt mir einiges davon nicht. Also
überzeugt mich jetzt nicht, dass ich sagen würde, okay, ich schmeiß mein selbstkonfiguriertes
weg oder so. Ist okay, aber bietet für mich jetzt nicht so viel Mehrwert, weil vieles
komplett anders ist, wie ich es haben will. Und ich denke halt, die Leute, die einfach
nur ein System haben wollen, was funktioniert, so auf klassische Art und Weise mit Desktop,
die verwenden wahrscheinlich auch kein E3. Also wird es wahrscheinlich darauf rauslaufen,
dass E3 weiterhin für Leute ist, die gerne selbst customisieren. Ja, ich bin gespannt,
was da war. Die Leiste, Ro-Fi auf D, okay. Kein Emoji Picker. F9 macht was. Ach nee,
haben die ab. Mod plus T, Windows-Switcher benutze ich so gut wie nie. F10 macht was,
keine Ahnung. Ach, es ist auskommentiert. Greenclip gibt es noch auf Mod C. Ah nee,
ist auch auskommentiert, okay. Ja, gut, die E3 Konfig muss ich sagen, so sehr schocken
tut die mich nicht. Vielleicht gibt es ja noch irgendwas, was ich entdecke, was mir gefällt
an der Konfig. Was haben wir hier unten? Knöpfe für, ah, das sind Shortcuts für Programme
für Leute, die gerne in Leisten klicken. Okay, ich klicke nicht gerne Leisten, also
für mich ist das nix. Was hatten die für eine Status-Leiste? Hab ich jetzt gar nicht
geguckt. Status, E3 Blocks. Ah, weiß nicht. So, Up, Down, Batterie. Das ist natürlich
auch doof, dass sie keinen GTK Darkseam haben. Aber man kann sich die Lautstärke ändern,
gut. Tastatur layout. Oder was war immer, was ist das? Ach so. Muss ich ehrlich sagen,
schockt mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr. Also E3 gefällt mir nicht so gut. Seriously, ist
es nicht so der Wahnsinn. Jetzt gucken wir uns aber mal die anderen Oberflächen an und
da probieren wir dann auch mal aus, ob vielleicht irgendwie was anderes noch vorkonfiguriert
kommt. Was haben wir denn so standardmäßig alles drauf? Hält sich ja arg in Grenzen.
Wir haben was zum Auflösung, Switchern, äh, Switchern, was zum Auflösung, Switchen,
Switches Pack und Endpack-Programm. Endeavor OS Quickstart Installer. Wie installiere ich
denn jetzt verschiedene Desktop Environments? Kann ich das wirklich nur im Setup machen?
Ich glaube, wir müssen das Setup noch mal ausführen. Also zurückrollen auf den Snapshot.
Ich halte 50 Milliarden. Danke schön für den Sub. Tja. Nö, wurde noch nicht thematisiert.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, warum. Pacman Gruppen. Ja, ich hab gehofft, das haben sie. Weil
die Pacman Gruppen bringen ja nichts. Dann habe ich ja wahrscheinlich nicht die Endeavor
OS Default-Config dafür. Also das ist alles nicht so wirklich, wie ich es gerne hätte
mit i3. Das heißt aus dem Grund. Das ist jetzt im Deboot, was wir haben. Also kann durchaus
sein, dass das so ist. Da habe ich mir jetzt überhaupt keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Interessiert mich auch nicht, solange es funktioniert. Aber die Config ist irgendwie nicht so mein
Fall, muss ich sagen. Probieren wir mal was anderes aus. Ich fürchte. Wellcome vielleicht?
Kann man da verschiedene Desktop Environments installieren? Schau mal EOS Package List.
Okay, Moment. Was? EOS Minus Package List. Minus Minus List. Aha. Minus Minus Install.
Okay. Also dann machen wir das doch mal. Nehmen wir mal. Okay, i3 war jetzt nicht so. Nehmen
wir mal. Ja, das habe ich gehört. Ich bin aber der Meinung, Linux braucht nicht noch
mehr Desktop-Oberflächen. Ich meine, es kann sich jeder selbstverständlich in seiner Freizeit
programmiertechnisch austoben, wie er will. Oh, Monkeys. Wir brauchen aber nicht noch
mehr Desktop Interfaces. Wir brauchen vielleicht mal zur Abwechslung ein paar gescheite Desktop-Oberflächen.
Warning. Skipping. Na gut. Alles klar. Enter. Default. Selection. Wunderbar. Yes. Sie haben
den Pac-Man-Switch an. Dass es aussieht wie Pac-Man. Lul. Eventuell eine Alternative.
Ja, da kommen jetzt die ganzen Wayland-Fans und sagen, aber es gibt doch Wayland. Ja,
das Dumme ist, Wayland funktioniert aber in der VM nicht gescheit. Wenn es funktioniert,
mag das nice sein. So. Okay, ich hoffe mal, dass wir jetzt einfach auslocken können.
Und dann Mate Desktop auswählen. Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Da ist es doch
hier. Mate. Mal schauen, ob das jetzt Endeavor OS vorkonfiguriert daherkommt. Leute, ist
das jetzt Endeavor OS vorkonfiguriertes Mate oder nicht? Nee, oder? Ist es glaube ich
nicht? Hä? Dann ist doch mal wieder. Das, was ich gesagt habe, müssen wir machen. Revert
to Snapshot. Yes. Wir installieren jetzt einfach richtig hässlich. Ja. Wir installieren es
jetzt einfach über den Installer. Desktop. Back. Wir installieren jetzt einfach mehrere.
Wir machen uns jetzt gar keinen großen. Wir installieren jetzt einfach alle, die es gibt
und gucken uns das gleich an. Warum soll ich das jetzt jedes Mal dafür neu durchklicken
hier? Xfc Desktop, KD Desktop, Gnome Desktop, Cinnamon, Budgie, LXD, alles, gib ihm, volle
Pulle. Nur i3 nicht. I3 brauchen wir nicht. I3 hatten wir schon. Next. Mach du doch einen
gescheiten den Window Manager Champ, oder? Erase. Ok, Encrypt lassen wir jetzt mal bleiben.
Brauchen wir nicht. Swap. Next. X. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Massify IQ Passwort.
Summary installed. Yes. Sollte jetzt ja zackig gehen. Schauen wir uns die anderen Interfaces
mal an und dann gucken wir mal. Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, die anderen Sachen müssen wir. Normalerweise
gucke ich ja immer gerne so Sachen wie, benutze die Distro Flatpak oder Snap oder irgendwelche
Spezialdinger. Wie sieht es mit YouTube auf Firefox Chrome aus? Aber das Problem ist,
das ist halt ganz normales Artstilungs. Eigentlich können wir alles damit beantworten, indem
wir uns mein normales Artstilungs angucken. Das wird nämlich alles dort genauso sein.
Kaum Sperenz. Wir können sogar Super Tox, Super Tox, äh, Card installieren und rumfahren
und das wird dann auch funktionieren. Gibt es extra Scripts? Ja, aber das will ich doch,
dass die das für mich machen, sonst kann ich auch alles von Hand, von Hand, ähm, konfigurieren.
Worm, da bin ich mal gespart. Habe ich Worm jetzt auch installiert? Ach nee, Community
Editions. Wo gab es die denn? Jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich. Wo konnte man denn die Community
Editions jetzt auswählen? War das, war das auch irgendwo hier? Ach, im Installer hier,
hier irgendwo. Ah, install Community Editions. Okay, also werden wir einmalig noch installieren
müssen, nachdem wir das jetzt hier durchgeguckt haben. Okay, das, das, das probieren wir tatsächlich
nochmal aus und dann gucken, was es da noch gibt. Hast du mal die Stämme gespielt? Boah,
das ist irgendein Browser Game gewesen, was 2000 rum angesagt war. Das kann durchaus
sein, dass ich da mal ein bisschen gespielt habe, ja. Was ist denn Worms? Das will ich
auch mal ausprobieren. Habe ich noch nie gehört. Gucken wir mal ein paar Bilder von an. Worms
Window Manager. A dynamic, dynamic, tag-based, written in Nim. Okay, Leute, also es ist ja
keine Programmiersprache zu Niche und abgedreht, dass da nicht irgendwie einer was drin, drin
write it. Written in Nim. Source, okay, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Worm Nim. Die Sprache
sieht ganz okay aus. Wobei, was ist, was ist? Alles klar.
Alter, okay, die, die, die Syntag sieht nicht okay aus. Aber was ist das denn? Sternchen
zwischendrinne, return type hier und dann ein gleich und das ist ja, das, das sieht
ja noch hässlicher aus als Rust an der Stelle. Der Rest ist okay, aber das hier, guck mal
hier. Okay, und ist wahrscheinlich das gleiche wie plus quasi string, concat, so, also quasi
das, was bei anderen Sprachen plus ist. Warum hier ein Sternchen steht, kein plus ein Schimmer?
Ah, das ist also Nim, okay. Man lernt nie aus. Okay, all done. Restart now, done. Pointer,
Pointer, was Pointer? Steht da sonst nichts dabei? Oh, wir müssen die CD wieder ausmachen.
Disconnect, jetzt neu starten. Endeavor und jetzt kriegen wir eine Auswahl mit acht Desktop
Environments oder so. Max, wo change ich jetzt die Desktop Environments? Da. Okay, wir haben
zur Auswahl Gnome. Moment, ist das, ist das, ist das Wayland, ist das eine Wayland Session
standardmäßig? Nee, das ist, das ist eine X Session. In der VM funktioniert Wayland
nicht richtig. Wie kann ich denn feststellen, ob es, es funktioniert auch nicht richtig,
oder? Wie kann ich dann feststellen, in welchem, welchem X System das Ganze läuft? Ach, Neo
Fetch, ja, du hast recht. Aber das mal, ist es jetzt denen ernst, dass man jetzt kein
Startmenü mehr hat, sondern immer hier drücken muss, oder wie? Was haben die sich denn da
wieder ausgedacht, man? WM? Nee. Und wo sieht man jetzt, ob es Wayland ist oder, oder X?
KGX? Was zum Teufel ist KGX? Was soll man machen? Echo? XXXDG? Oh, Session Type. Wayland.
Oh Leute, guck mal. Wayland, Wayland geht ja in der VM halbwegs. Mal schauen, mal schauen,
ob Copy Paste auch funktioniert. Wait a minute. Es geht mittlerweile Copy Paste aus Wayland?
Da haben die ja das meiste gefixt, was mich immer abgefuckt hat. Der Screen refresht ordentlich.
Okay, ich glaube, es wird mal wieder Zeit, es wird mal wieder Zeit, Sway zu testen. Wayland
gefixt in VMWare. Hast du schon was von Hyperland gehört? Ja, habe ich schon mal irgendwo gelesen.
Copy Paste und Screen Refresh. Was ist das für ein hässliches Terminal? Das sieht aus
wie ein Terminal, was versucht, auch Windows Terminal zu machen, aber noch schlechter ist.
Was ist das für ein Terminal? Man kann hier gar nichts einstellen. Man kann auch nicht
mal die Schrifte ändern. What the fuck, was ist das? Konsole. This Terminal sucked, Alter.
Da dreh ich jetzt schon durch, wenn ich das benutzen muss. Okay, wie heißt das? Hyperland?
Aber sag mal ernsthaft, wie startet man denn jetzt was im Gnome im neuen? Nur noch hier
drüber oder was? Ich kann jetzt nicht mal die Taste drücken und sagen, ich will jetzt
Terminal starten. Ach, das geht noch. Ach, tippen kann man. Ach, das geht. Okay, das ist das. Okay,
dann ist das in Ordnung. Github Hyperland. Hyperland WM. Hyperland is a highly customizable,
dynamic, tailing, Wayland composite that doesn't sacrifice on its looks. Okay, ich bin interessiert
daran, das auszuprobieren. Interesting. So, Dark Reader, Mozilla, Ed. Ach, so zufällig
noch ein hetzner Promo Code? Nee, keiner funktioniert. Das haben sie immer noch nicht auf die Reihe
gekriegt. Aber eine Sache haben sie auch schon mal nicht gut gemacht. Wobei, ich hab ja auch
kein Dark Theme ausgewählt. Wie macht man? Leute, das ist, ich muss ehrlich sagen, so Gnome
Settings. Is weird champ. Beispielsweise Appearance. Okay, wie machen wir Dark Theme jetzt? Dark.
Bisschen ruckelig ist es noch. Background. Und Davos. Hat es kein, hat es kein, wie minimiert
man dann in Gnome ein Fenster? Gibt's das net, oder? Wie, gar nicht. Braucht man Addons?
Das ist ernsthaft? Man fand wirklich, nur, dass ich das richtig
verstehe. Nur, dass ich das richtig verstehe. Die haben das minimieren von Fenstern ausgebaut,
ja? Sind die komplett bescheuert, oder wie? Warum? Also, wenn ich, wenn ich einen Tiling
Window Manager verwende, dann brauch ich keine Fenster zu minimieren. Aber wenn ich einen
normalen Window, dann muss ich doch Fenster minimieren können. Ich mein, man kann doch
einfach Fenster über Fenster lagern. Das geht auch, aber dann, dann blickst du irgendwann
gar nicht mehr durch. Nee, mittlere Maustaste auf Taskleiste geht nicht. Guck, mach ich
gerade. Man kann das in Tweaks, okay, wie, okay, okay. Das macht mich erfertigt. Minimieren
ist outdated, wer braucht sowas? Okay, Tweaks, oder ist das ein Zusatzprogramm, was ich installieren
muss? Tweaks, Tweaks, Tweaks. Extension Management has been moved to GNOME Extensions. Was bin
ich da überhaupt sehend, was wollen die von mir? GNOME Extensions? Extensions, ah, hier
gibt's Extensions, okay. Also, ich kann mit der mittleren Maustaste so viel klicken, wie
ich will, da passiert nichts. Ja klar, will ich minimieren, wenn ich keinen Tiling Window
Manager verwende, will ich minimieren. Ansonsten würde ich den Tiling Window Manager verwenden.
Okay, und, und wo, Appearance. Quogier. Und wo kann ich jetzt Windows hier, hm? Click
to focus minimise, gibt es nicht. Mini. Aha. Ah, so. Seriously, die haben sie doch nimmer
all. Die sind doch wirklich nimmer ganz dicht, dass defaultmäßig Fenster minimieren aus
ist, die sind doch komplett bescheuert. Left, right, okay, das ist doch wirklich, guck mal,
sogar kaputt, wenn man das auf left rime. Middle click, minimise. Ja, das ist tatsächlich
ganz nice, wenn man das so und das machen kann. Ja, das finde ich, äh. Aber im Firefox geht
die mittlere Maustaste nicht, okay. Was, wo ist es denn hin? Wo, wo ist es hin? Ich habe
so minimiert. Ach hier. Hä? Okay, das ist Sixhead Bedienkonzept, das erschließt sich
mir nicht. Und jetzt kann ich meine minimierten, minimierten Anwendungen aus so einem komischen
Menü, das ist doch abfuck, umständlich, oder? Oder nicht? Und jetzt kann ich track und dropen
und was mache ich damit jetzt? Auf zwei Interstop tracken, okay. Brauchst dash to dock extension?
Okay. Erst mal, Extensions hatten wir ja auch. Also ich weiß nicht, also ich war ja noch
nie ein großer Gnome-Fan, ja. Dash. Ach nee, Extensions. Ich soll ernsthaft die Extensions
von irgendeiner Webseite herunterladen? Dash. Nee, dock. Was, dock to dash, was?
Und jetzt?
Alter, ist das Schrott. Das ist ja Hyper Schrott, man. Das will ich nicht verwenden,
seriously. Das will ich wirklich nicht verwenden. Du musst die, eine Browser-Extension. Alter,
meine Güte. Fack, Alter, was haben die sich denn ausgedacht? Also ich muss die Gnome-Extension
für Mozilla installieren. Äh. Moment, das kommt nicht mal aus dem Addon-Store. Das ist
doch, das ist doch eine komplette Verarschung mittlerweile.
Ja, das ist halt 10 Jahre so. Ich benutze ja Gnome auch nicht. Naja, funktioniert trotzdem
nicht. Was, was haben die sich denn da für einen Schrott ausgedacht? Das ist ja so schlecht.
Alter, wer benutzt das jetzt immer? Ernsthaft? Gibt es irgendjemand, der das so raw ohne
ordentlich vorkonfiguriert benutzt? Das ist doch mal richtig für'n Arsch. Ich mein, da
kannst du ja schon fast das Ubuntu-Gnome besser verwenden. Chrome? Ich bin doch in Firefox.
Seriously, Leute, das ist mal richtig für'n Arsch. Aber der Rest, naja, gut. Ist da wohl
Schlussstudio Code oder sowas? Kate? Ach, das gibt's immer noch. Plumer. Nun ja. Das,
was mich jetzt tatsächlich ja interessiert hat, ist, ob Wayland funktioniert und Wayland
funktioniert anscheinend. Deswegen probieren wir mal noch folgendes. Settings. Das müssen
wir jetzt ausprobieren, ob das alles ordentlich funktioniert. Display. Accelerate 3D-Grafics.
Und mal ausschalten. Power off. Und jetzt zeigen wir 3D-Beschleunigung für die VM an.
Ah, gib ihm. Mal gucken, ob's dann, ob dann Wayland mehr rumspackt oder ob's dann einfach
trotzdem funktioniert. Aber ich find's gut, dass die Wayland in der VM gefixt haben.
Das macht mich zuverlässig, dass wir demnächst vielleicht auch ein bisschen was anderes ausprobieren
können.
Ähm. Gibt es da auch was, was Kompets drinnen hat? Ich mag Kompets. Mit dem drehenden Cube
und sowas. Das war früher der Shit. Schlechthin. Also ernsthaft, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie
das ernsthaft jemand benutzen kann. Es ist mir ein komplettes Rätsel, wie man das hier
benutzen. Also da krieg ich ja Anfälle bei. Ok. Oslong Logout. Was haben wir sonst noch
zu bieten? NixOS, das hab ich sogar glaub ich schon mal aufgeschrieben, dass wir das
machen wollen, oder? Endeavor OS. Haben wir heute ausprobiert. Unix Porn angeguckt haben
wir auch. Mate und Kompets. Oh geil, Alter. Das, das Kompets beste. So, also wo kann
man das jetzt umschalten? Moment, das ist das hier? Nee. Ähm. Ah! Hatte ich, hatte
ich hier unten nicht doch irgendwo einen Knopf vorher, wo man die Desktop an Wiremanns umschalten
konnte? Wo ist der hin? Ah ne, ich muss das anklicken. Ok. Ok Leute, was wollen wir als
nächstes benutzen? Was wollen wir als nächstes ausprobieren? Also XFCE müssen wir uns hier
angucken. XFCE. Wir probieren Mate aus. Mate ist noch der Desktop, wo ich immer denke,
ok, den könnte ich noch am ehesten benutzen. Vielleicht nehmen wir XFCE noch, aber i3
ist der beste. XFCE müssen wir nicht ausprobieren. Openbox. Openbox ist nice, das habe ich tatsächlich
mal eine Weile verwendet. Nee, Fluxbox habe ich mal eine Weile verwendet. Openbox, da
gibt es nicht viel zu zeigen. Das ist äußerst minimalistisch, Leute. Das war es glaube ich
schon. Fertig. Das ist die Oberfläche. Du hast ein Rechtsklickmenü, um was zu starten
und das war es. Ich persönlich mag das ja sehr, ich mag das ja gerne, wenn es minimalistisch
ist. Das ist halt schon extrem minimalistisch dann. Funktioniert aber richtig gut mit Compets
und so zusammen. Moment, das muss ich mal kurz ausprobieren, ob Compets... Compets,
das Beste. Das muss jetzt sein. Ja, ich mag, ich finde Openbox ist cool. Openbox hat was,
das habe ich früher ganz, das habe ich wirklich lange verwendet. Also quasi bevor ich auf
dem i3 Train unterwegs war, habe ich Openbox verwendet. Das kann halt nix, aber das reicht.
Moment, Compets, ich brauche jetzt mal schnell den Würfel. Darf ich ein Hyperland Unix-Porn-Videos
schicken? Ja, du kannst einfach einen Link auf den Thread von Unix-Porn schicken.
Ja, erinnere mich dran, dass wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Doch, kann sein. So, Compets. Compets. Und dann Minus Minus Replays. Jawoll.
Erstmal komplett gecrashed. Geil. Okay, einmal prob... Einmal probiere ich es noch aus.
Moment, kann das sein, dass das jetzt auch unter Wayland oder so läuft? Deswegen...
Nee, X, okay. Compets Replays. Ist Compets kaputt oder was? Compets ist Poggers, aber
als
dass es so kacke ausschaut das ist quasi gnome gnome 2 im endeffekt das
ist gnome 2 mate ist ist ist quasi weiterentwickelt das gnome 2 system ich
muss euch ehrlich sagen mir ist das auch wenn es jetzt halt hier vielleicht ein
bisschen schlecht vorkonfiguriert das ja mir ist das hier so viel lieber als das
was ich gerade von gnome 4 oder was es ist gesehen habe das das kann man das
kann man nämlich wenigstens normal benutzen hier ohne dass man irgendwie
durchdreht geht das ist die best kacke sollte halt fehlen ja der fehlen die
ganzen irgendwie kann sich nicht so ganz entscheiden ob jetzt dark oder darker
oder vor allem ist es custom nehmen wir mal nehmen wir mal dass das nehmen wir
mal dass die ford ist ja auch kaputt da kannst du so stell dir mal vor leute
guck mal kannst du fenster minimieren können könnt ihr euch das vorstellen
alle ja das ist das ist das sieht jetzt zwar sehr alt altbacken aus das haben
die auch also da muss man ja den endeffer os leuten mal sagen schön
vorkonfiguriert ist es nicht
schön vorkonfiguriert ist nicht da nehme ich lieber da nehme ich lieber mit mit
mit made und pitts replace ah moment habe ich das kommt ich habe das kompens
ohne habe ich habe ich das kommt jetzt ohne dekorator und so installiert ja
glaub schon haben wir nämlich keine keine keine
fensterrahmen tc sm so das sieht ja es sieht ja pro aus
beste ist alles ist alles ziemlich mies vorkonfiguriert
warte mal je kompens kompens
ohne dekorator was macht endeva jetzt besonders ja es ist eine art schlugs mit
einfache installation und halt vorkonfiguriert desktops wobei ich sagen
muss das vorkonfigurierte wobei ich jetzt hier am rumsauen bin gerade muss man ja
auch mehr ehrlich sagen
kompens
ok die dekorator sind nicht da aber ich will ich will leute das das geht jetzt
nicht anders cc cc sm ich brauche jetzt hier den desktop cube der ist mich
enable desktop cube und wie hat man den jetzt ein control alt down
nee ich habe lange kein kompens mehr gescheit
verwendet wie behavior appearance oder gibt es key mappings auf wie ging das
jetzt noch mal zu lang her dass ich kompens zeug made compatibility ok alles
gut beat muss auf general options
wie geht das mit den shortcuts jetzt noch mal
water effect blur effect wobbly windows das allerwichtigste leute das
aller allerwichtigste wobbly windows ich hoffe ich hoffe dass alles
funktioniert jetzt
bester effekt leute
so mag ich das das war damals der shit alle jeder hat wobbly windows benutzt
der effekt ist alt aber es der beste wobbly windows best ever
wie ging das mit dem cube jetzt geht es ja wie ging das wie ging das mit dem cube
desktop cube. Anfall, control, alt, down. Aha! Poggers. Appearance. Man konnte da noch
mehr einstellen. One big cube. Das, das war nice. Aber Moment, man konnte den Würfel
doch drehen. Wie ging das jetzt hier nochmal? Inside cube? Muss man das immer wieder neu
starten dafür? Ne. Du musst rotate cube? Ah ja! Ok, das war was anderes. Ich muss
rotate cube. Control, alt, button. Ach ja, das meine ich. Beste. Desktop cube. Wo habe
ich das jetzt mit inside cube gemacht? Das wollte will ich gar nicht haben. Leute, wo
war das jetzt mit inside cube? Hier, da, inside cube. Hier. So will ich das haben. Compets
war das beste. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum Compets sich so nicht so richtig durchgesetzt
hat. Das ist wirklich, das ist cooler als das was es unter Windows gibt und was es unter
Mac OS und so gibt. Ich weiß, das ist irgendwie schon Spielerei, aber das hat, das hat, da
war mal so richtig ein Aushängeschild. Man muss aber sagen, ähm, viele Desktop Environments
haben was ähnliches mittlerweile integriert. Halt nicht ganz so abgedrehter Shit wie Compets,
aber Compets ist extrem porr aus. Man, man konnte glaub sogar einstellen, dass das Ding
mehrere Seiten hat. Kann sogar ein Bild, komm, man kann sogar ein Bild im Hintergrund hinterlegen.
Komm, jetzt hat man sogar, jetzt hat man sogar ein Himmel dabei. So, und man konnte doch
irgendwie einstellen, ich weiß aber nicht wo, wie viele Seiten der Kram hat der Würfel.
Ja, das UI-Design ist made, das hat ja mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Desktop wenig zu tun.
Okay, das weiß ich, man konnte, man konnte mehrere Seiten einstellen, vielleicht ist
auch bei Rotate Cube drinne. Speed, Zoom, Acceleration. Übrigens, das finde ich eine
super praktische Geschichte hier für Leute, die nicht gut sehen. Guck mal, da kannst du
hier super, also quasi Zoom, wirklich ordentlicher Zoom über die Grafikkarte, das war schon
ganz nice. So, hin und her schieben. Ähm, ich will trotzdem mal, wie ging das, das Desktop
Wall war auch so ein Switcher, der war ganz cool. Aber wie ging das noch mal mit dem Color?
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie man da mehrere Seiten einstellt, bin ich, bin ich gerade zu planlos.
Oh, habe ich irgendwas kaputt gemacht. Also man konnte, man konnte da bis zu 10 Seiten
oder so einstellen. Was? General Size? Okay. Shape of the Cube can be altered by changing
the Horizontal Virtual Size in General Options Desktop Size. Nö. Anscheinend nicht. Im Tab?
Ach so. Ah ja, hier, genau. Warten wir mal, hier 5 und da 10, jetzt pass mal auf, jetzt
sieht es richtig eklig aus gleich. Äh, nee, was ist das? Guck mal. Jetzt kannst du erst
mal eine halbe Stunde, eine halbe Stunde scrollen. Das ist mega cool. Ja, ich, ich hab das früher
immer benutzt. Leider ist Compets nicht mal so, nicht mal so angesagt. Ey, man muss es
ja auch nicht mit Made benutzen. Kannst eigentlich mit allen möglichen benutzen. Komm, wir machen
es mal zu, was ist eigentlich, wenn ich, wenn ich 2 einstelle? Okay, dann muss man so machen
und bei 3 ist es dann quasi ein Dreieck. Okay. Ist eigentlich auch cool so ein Dreieck, oder?
Dreieck Desktop. Ja, das war, egal, das habe ich früher richtig, richtig gefeiert. Ähm,
zumindest, man kann auch, man kann auch andere coole Sachen machen. Es gibt auch written
in Russian. Blur Windows. Water Effect. Control. Super. Man konnte da schon extrem sinnlose
Sega mitmachen. Das hat die Welt gebraucht unbedingt, ne? Blur Windows. Gut, das klappt
nur bei manchen. Man konnte auch noch, wo ist Fire? Moment, kein Fire Effekt. Wo ist
das alles hin? Da gab es doch noch viel mehr früher. Das war doch fast das Beste. Muss
man auch Zusatz? Effekte installieren vielleicht? Wo ist der Feuer Effekt? Hier. Compets Fusion
Extra Plugins brauchen wir wahrscheinlich. Fusion. Compets Fusion 2, 3. Was ist Compets
Manager? Compets Fusion Starter Programm? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was ich da
gerade installiere und ob ich es nicht kaputt mache. Aber wir machen das jetzt einfach mal.
Aber Compets, ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, das gab es 2006, 2007 rum. Unter einem der
ersten Ubuntu's schon. Das war der Shit damals. Da gab es noch Barrel anstatt Compets mit
mehr Effekten und sowas drin. Aber es hat sich nie so richtig durchgesetzt. Ganz im
Ernst, ich finde es viel cooler, sowas hier zu haben als dieses komische neue unbedienbare
Gnome. Wir gucken uns gleich auf die anderen Desktop-Oberflächen an. Erstmal gucken,
wie lange der hier braucht, um den Kram zu installieren. Du hast mehr Prozesse als in
Windows. Tja. Aber je nach Desktop-Environment, allen wird es wahrscheinlich trotzdem viel
weniger Hintergrundaktivität haben. Vor allem Upload zu Microsoft hat es weniger. Wobei
ich habe gestern mit Bill Gates telefoniert und er sagt, die Telemetrie-Auswertung in Windows
ist nur zum Verbessern für Windows. Also es geht nicht darum, irgendwie was mitzuschneiden.
Und das glaube ich ihm natürlich auch. Da passiert nichts, Leute. Windows macht nur
gute Sachen. Saved, ja. Ok, Compets, wie hieß dieses Ding? Compets Manager, für was
ist das? Ok, nice. Funktioniert ja richtig gut. Und was soll das machen? Ok, ich habe
keinen Plastenschimmer. TCSM. Fire. Nein, nein, nein, nein, das meine ich nicht. Wo
ist der Feuereffekt, wenn das Fenster abbrennt? Gibt es das nicht mehr? Haben die das rausgeschmissen?
Ich will den Feuereffekt, wenn das Fenster geschlossen wird. Nicht diesen Shit. Cube
Gears? Was ist das? Ok, wir können Paint Fire on Screen. Shift Super Button 1. Es ist
so unglaublich sinnvoll, alter. Unsinnig. Das gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr. Weil nicht,
dass es in irgendeiner Art und Weise Sinn machen will. Aber das Feuer beim Window gibt
es wohl nicht mehr. Im Minimal ist Effekt drin. Ok, das kann sein. Nö. Egal. Scheiß
drauf. Genug rumgebastelt mit Compets. Aber trotzdem, Compets ist immer noch eines der
geilsten Sachen, die sie sich da je ausgedacht haben. Gut. Wie lockt man hier aus? System
Logout. Logout. Du wolltest dir das Reddit Video angucken? Ja, wenn man hier den Kram
fertig angeschaut hat. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Made ist schlecht vorkonfiguriert,
mir überhaupt nicht. KDE Openbox? Was ist das für eine Kombination? KDE Openbox? Hä?
Das ist eine KDE. Was hat das jetzt genau mit Openbox zu tun? Man weiß es nicht. Logout.
Ja, Compets. Keine Ahnung. Also ok, Knomb nämlich mal ganz viel Abstand. Made war Openbox
auch schlecht vorkonfiguriert. Plasma. Äh. Plasma ist doch das neue KDE, oder? Sieht
es jetzt anders aus? Ne, das ist genau das gleiche. Genau, so hätte ich das erwartet.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, das geht ja. Das kann man wenigstens noch normal als Desktop hier
durchgehen lassen und verwenden. Ich mag das, aber es ist mal alle mal besser als Knomb.
Das hat mich ja mal richtig abgefuckt hier. So, was haben wir denn hier? KDE ist halt auch
wieder so ein Ding. KDE hat schon wieder zu viel Konfigurationszeug. Das hat so viel Konfigurationszeug,
dass ich noch nicht mal weiß, wie ich überhaupt in die Settings reinkomme. Hier, Configure,
Profiles. Ne. Wie stelle ich denn die Schriftart überhaupt um? Manage Profiles? Ne. Ah, ich
muss neues Profil erstellen. Okay. Herkel-Profile. Ach, und da kann ich jetzt sagen, Appearance,
Tabs. Wo ist die Schriftart? Das ist halt das Problem, was ich mit KDE habe. Da finde
ich immer nix. Appearance. Ach, hier. Oh, Hack-Default-Installation, sehr gut. Beste
Schriftart. Hack 16. Apply. Gib ihm. Naisu, Naisu. Das haben wir nicht. Hack 16. Ach,
man muss Set as Default machen. Okay, das ist eigentlich ganz okay. Also KDE geht, finde
ich in dem Fall vollkommen in Ordnung. Kann man sich direkt geben. Wayfire. Das klingt
aber so, als geht das nur mit Wayland. Also das geht, finde ich, echt in Ordnung. Ist
auch schön vorkonfiguriert, finde ich, kann man durchaus benutzen. Gut, ich meine, ich
mag halt die Usability, also ne, das Look and Feel von KDE nicht, aber es ist mir allemal
lieber, wirklich, allemal lieber als Gnome. Also ich meine, das kann man doch hier noch,
das geht doch, das geht doch eigentlich voll klar. Da findet man alles, also ich glaube
ganz ehrlich, von allem, was wir hier ausprobiert haben, kommt ein normaler User hier mit, also
normaler Ex-Windows-User, der vielleicht auch mit der Einstellung so ein bisschen ran
geht, hier mit doch echt noch am besten klar. Ja, Gnome ist super, richtig super an Gnome
ist, dass man keine Fenster minimieren kann. Ganz furchtbar Sinn. Wollen die mich eigentlich
komplett verarschen alle oder was? Wer soll denn den Schrott verwenden? Es geht ja nicht
mal die Basics, mann. Was ist denn das? Läuft es auf? Ich weiß nicht worauf das läuft.
Session-Type. X. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht liegt es an der 3D. Wow. Leute, da ist was
kaputt. Da stimmt was nicht mit meinem Browser-Fenster. Das ist eine VM, ja? Das ist wirklich way too
dank. Was hat das denn mit WSL zu tun, Chat?
Okay, interessant. Also ansonsten ist es ganz gut. Also ich muss sagen, ich finde es optisch
von allen Desktops. Ach, WSL bedeutet wahrscheinlich. Ah, das muss man mal wissen. Schmutz, Digga,
WSL. Also von den vorkonfigurierten Desktops ist das hier mit Abstand der hübscheste von
Endeavor OS. Kommt man auch am besten mit klar. Macht ganz guten Eindruck. Wir gucken
mal, ob Videos abspielen. Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, von all dem, was ich bisher gesehen
habe, also neben meinem E3, ja, neben meinem E3 Vorkonfiguration, wäre mir das von allem,
was ich bisher gesehen habe, noch am liebsten. So, ich probiere mal kurz was aus. Bei Openbox
kann nicht allzu viel kaputt gehen, da gibt es ja nichts. Opera? Was ist denn da eigentlich
alles vorenstattet? Das FPS-Gesicht ist das erste, was man findet bei Google. Hallo Leute,
hier ist der Max und was meint ihr, was die schnellste Möglichkeit ist? Das muss, das
muss an... Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und ich merke immer wieder... Das muss an Kanye
liegen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie YouTube mit Werbung aussieht. Ich gucke nie YouTube mit
Werbung. Was, wenn ich mir das hier angucke, auch eine sehr gute Idee ist, es... Also immer
nur mit Werbeblocker zu gucken. Ich muss sagen, das Gameplay in dem Video ist gar nicht mal
so übel, ne? Und die Dudes da, Alter. Wieso nicht checken? Das Gameplay in dem Video ist
gar nicht schlecht. Ja, ich kann mich jetzt nach ein paar Wochen Abstand angucken und ich
finde mein eigenes Gameplay nicht schlecht. Ja, ist so. Aja. Achtunddreißigjähriger Boomer-Owned-Junge
Tryhards. Und das nächste, der nächste Club ist eigentlich noch besser. Moment. Der nächste,
den finde ich, den hier finde ich richtig gut. Den hier. Bam. Fliegt er rum. Die werden richtig
gefarmt hier gleich. Ne, das hat leider nur 25k oder so, 20k Aufrufe. Guck mal, wie sie
reinrennen. Wie er hinterhercharged. Ja, wäre das nur ein gutes Game geworden, mann. Das...
Dann hätte ich wirklich was zum Spielen gehabt. Guck mal, wie sie plattgemacht werden.
Bam. Bam. Next. Da geht's durch. Die werden schon hart gebashed, muss man schon sagen.
Ja, das ist Twitter-Emojis, die wir hier haben. Trimoji. Also, die Twitter-Emojis und Firefox
sind mehr oder weniger die gleichen. Dadge. Und jetzt, die nächsten, guckt mal, die nächsten
werden auch übelst geklatscht jetzt wieder. Vor allem, wie sie es auch nicht schenken.
Leute, wir sind nicht hier, um uns Battlefield-Gameplay anzugucken. Ja, ich weiß, aber ich muss...
Ich bin tatsächlich echt zufrieden mit den Clips hier, gerade so, wenn ich da so durchgucke.
Leider kann man mit gescheiten Battlefield-Clips nix reißen, weil Battlefield aktuell sauer
interessiert, was ja auch verständlich ist bei dem verkackten letzten Teil. Bam. Guck
mal, hier. Einer nach dem anderen. In your face. Zack, eine Runde hüpfen. Barney hoppen
geht immer noch. Next. Boah, ich hab da jetzt irgendwie 15 Leute gekillt oder so in ein
paar Minuten. Sehr nice. Okay. Wo waren wir stehen geblieben? Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Ah, wir wollten. Okay. Nächsten Desktop angucken. Also, ja. Zack. Also, was haben wir jetzt ausgebildet?
Jetzt haben wir alles durch. Es bleibt noch Cinnamon übrig, Batschi, LXDE gucken wir
nicht an und dann nur noch LXQT. Das war's. Okay. Also, komm, fangen wir mal an. Batschi.
Okay, ganz kurz guck ich mal LXDE rein. Das hab ich früher ganz gerne verwendet. Sieht
immer noch aus wie von 2005. Ist halt sehr leichtgewichtig und klein. Ansonsten gibt's
glaube ich relativ wenig Grund, warum man heutzutage noch LXDE verwenden sollte. Crash
das jetzt eigentlich auch, wenn ich sage, Kompets. Der Rest ist aber kaputt unten. Okay. Wie logge
ich jetzt aus? Leute, wie logge ich aus, wenn es broken ist? X neu starten geht nicht.
Gut. Null. Was? Pangolin. Nee, ich kann jetzt nicht alle Desktop DES ausprobieren. Pangolin
Desktop. You are designed for written in Flutter. In Flutter? Des auf dem Desktop?
Ist das, ob das so eine gute Idee ist? Okay, LXDE. Batschi, guck mal was Batschi zu bieten
hat. Okay, faded faded schon mal hübsch ein. Ich glaube, das Fenstercheck nicht so ganz
vor ein Mauszeiger ist, oder? Sagt mal, können wir mal irgendeinen Desktop aufmachen ohne
absolut basic Probleme? Das ist so schlecht, was? Ohne Scheiß kann ich immer noch am besten.
Wobei, hey, das muss nicht unbedingt an Batschi liegen. Sekunde, das könnte auch an diesem
komischen Endeavor Programm liegen. Ja, das liegt, okay, die können nix dafür, das liegt
an diesem verkackten Endeavor Programm. Was ich jetzt, vor allem bei Workstation. Ich
muss sagen, das finde ich tatsächlich ganz hübsch. Hübsches, ist das Nautilus, Tuna,
was ist das? Nemo, ja, okay. Das ist tatsächlich ganz hübsch gemacht hier. Schönes Icon Theme.
Bisschen verkackt, die Mischung aus Dark und Light Theme. Ark Darker, aber hier in... Wobei,
das könnte sein, dass meine Gnome Settings das verkackt haben. Wobei, nee, meine Gnome
Settings sollten ja damit eigentlich gar nix zu tun haben. Ich glaube auch, dass sie das
ein bisschen gerippt haben aus Gnome, oder? Wie stellt man hier überhaupt... Warum gibt
es überhaupt Desktop Settings und Control Center? Was ist da... Was ist da der Unterschied?
Dark Theme, ah ja, so ist gut, so ist gut. Ja, ist so. Ja, ich hab bestimmt was kaputt
gemacht, indem ich es installiert habe. Da muss was kaputt sein. Also, ich hab keine
Ahnung, ob es ein Gnome Fork ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall deutlich angenehmer als
Gnome. Ich hab so viel Zeug drauf, weil ich im Setup 5 Desktop Umgebungen ausgewählt
habe. Also, das Setup erlaubt das. Wenn es natürlich so ist, dass sie sich in die Quere
haben, dann ist es ziemlich bescheuer, dass man das so überhaupt auswählen kann. Aber
wieso? Funktioniert doch eigentlich alles ganz gut. Also, was sollte jetzt hier... Ich
meine, außer, dass es viele Anwendungen gibt, aber das ist ja nicht das Problem. Ist das
das gleiche Farbschema? Ja, würde schon sagen. Das macht doch eigentlich auch einen ganz
kompetenten Eindruck. Jetzt gucken wir mal, wo das läuft. Echo. Session. X. Okay. Icons.
Ja, doch Standard. Standard Icons, die ist schon in Ordnung. Cursors. Ja, gut. Desktop.
Desktop Icons kann man auch ein- und ausschalten. Ist das wirklich ein Gnome-3-Fork oder was
ist das? Was bin ich da sehend? Du findest, es ist unqualifiziertes Linux-Gebäsche. Ja,
kannst du ja finden, aber ich hab das Ding nicht programmiert und dafür gesorgt, dass
ein Fenster sich nach links oben bewegt, wenn man es nach rechts unten zieht. Also, da
hab ich jetzt ja nichts für. Wenn ich den Fenster nach rechts unten ziehe und es geht
nach links oben, dann kann es ja schlecht mir als Mauszieher den Vorwurf machen, dass
es so ist. Ist ja nicht mein Problem. Mein VM-Setup. Ich betreibe den Kram nur in VMs
und andere Weite, ich funktioniere es ja auch. Mag sein, aber trotzdem. Seriously. Also,
das in der VM zu betreiben und dass ich dann nach rechts unten ziehe und es nach links
oben geht, ist trotzdem kaputt. Bei den anderen Fenstern scheint es ja sogar zu funktionieren.
Number of Virtual Desktop. Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich finde das hier deutlich schicker
als Gnome-3. Oder als Gnome-4. Was ist überhaupt die aktuelle Gnome-Version?
Ja, Fragment. Genau das ist es. So sieht es aus. Du hast bestimmt früher auch in Linux
Foren geschrieben, wenn Anwender irgendwelche Probleme haben, ja du musst erstmal lernen,
wie ein Computer funktioniert. Du solltest das nicht benutzen, bis du nicht genau weißt,
wie das alles abläuft. Das finde ich immer so geil, die Logik, man. Wir haben den Installer
durchgeklickt. Mailing-Liste, genau. Ich meine, wir haben den Installer durchgeklickt und
benutzen das jetzt. Und das Fenster geht nach rechts unten, zieht nach links oben. Was
gibt es da schön zu reden? Ja, was gibt es schön zu reden, dass KDE abkackt, wenn ich
ein Video abspiele? In meiner normalen Linux-VM funktioniert alles ohne jegliche Probleme.
Da kann ich, ok, das ist i3, da kann ich keine Fenster, aber ich kann Fenster ziehen, ja?
Ich kann Fenster ziehen, ich kann YouTube-Videos abspielen, es crasht nix, es funktioniert
einfach. So, wir gucken uns jetzt, da kannst du einfach mal weiter an. Was haben die hier
standardmäßig für einen Terminal? Das ist bestimmt Gnome-Terminal geforkt, oder? Ja,
das sieht aus wie das alte Gnome-Terminal, was tatsächlich ganz brauchbar war. Ich habe
jahrelang Gnome-Terminal verwendet, ich glaube in der alten, ich glaube in der alten VM haben
wir sogar noch Gnome-Terminal. Ich muss sagen, ich kann immer noch nicht ganz verstehen, warum
man, warum sie das Gnome-Terminal deprecated haben und jetzt irgendwie was neues basteln
wollen. Gnome-Terminal war vollkommen in Ordnung. Das neue Gnome-Terminal kann halt irgendwie
gar nichts mehr im Vergleich zu dem, aber das geht in Ordnung. Ja Leute, regt euch nicht
auf im Chat, kann ja jeder meinen was er will, mich stört das auch nicht großartig. Soll
sich jeder denken, was er will bei. Ist das? Ja, das ist quasi about, was ist das? Gnome-Terminal,
reicht doch. Wunderbar, Gnome-Terminal ist nice, das habe ich jahrelang benutzt. Jetzt
benutze ich mittlerweile West-Term. Irgendwie nimmt Gnome immer wieder Funktionen weg. Ja,
zum Beispiel, dass du Fenster minimieren kannst, wo man sich so fragt, warum? Warum ist Fenster
minimieren bloated? Warum muss das weg? Ah, guck mal, die haben Single-Click eingeschaltet,
das verwirrt mich auch. Mounts on Desktop, das ist vielleicht gar nicht schlecht, wenn
man USB-Laufwerke und sowas sehen will. Icons, virtual desktops, so Fonts, rave-n, was ist
rave-n? Ein Media-Player oder? Jaja, es ist unter VM-Ware kaputt, das ist richtig. Allerdings,
wenn ich auf einen anderen Desktop rüber-switche, hier auch in der gleichen VM, dann geht's.
Also da muss KDE schon irgendwelche komischen Dinge machen. Also was rave-n ist, schenke
ich fast. Die Buttons hier unten oder? Is that rave-n position? Is rave-n das Rechtsklick-Menü?
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was rave-n ist, seriously. Was auch immer. Bottom-Panel,
das macht doch aber einen relativ guten Eindruck hier. Das ist quasi ein Gnome-Fork-Inusable.
Ach, das ist das Notification-Center hier unten. Achso, das ist quasi dieses Ding hier
unter Windows, was auch schon keine Sau verwendet, oder? Okay, vielleicht ist es hier irgendwie
sinnvoller. Also zumindest kenne ich niemand, der das unter Windows verwendet. Notifications
ist ja ganz sinnvoll. Notify, Send, Kackel. Okay, und das landet jetzt hier drin? Nee,
anscheinend nicht. Ah, nach dem Timeout landet das hier drin. Das finde ich schick. Okay,
mit dem Kalender vielleicht nicht. Kann man das auch so installieren? Wie active wird
Batschi noch maintained? Weiß ich nicht. Raven. GitHub-Budgi-Desktop. Warum sollte das
nicht mehr aktiv maintained werden? Vor drei Stunden gab es die letzten Comets. Also, alles
top aktuell. Tja, was davon ist es denn jetzt? Raven. Raven-Notification-Linux. Das ist
bestimmt so ein Build-In. Das ist bestimmt so ein Build-In in Batschi. Das kann man bestimmt
nicht zusätzlich installieren, Raven. Geh ich mal von aus. Tatsächlich, ich finde das
hier sehr schick gemacht. Okay, Widgets mit Kalender und so, ganz ehrlich. Naja, das
bräuchte ich jetzt nicht. Aber der Rest ist eigentlich ganz nice. Nee, das kann man bestimmt
nicht zusätzlich installieren. Wir können gucken, ob... Wir können gucken, ob YouTube
hier funktioniert. Das hat wirklich irgendwelche Probleme. Ist aber komisch, dass es in Openbox
geht. In meiner anderen VM geht es nicht. Wir probieren mal wirklich, ob es an der 3D...
Aber das... Es ist bescheuert. Ich will ja 3D-Acceleration anhaben in der VM. Nee, es
ist anscheinend kein KDE-Problem. Es ist aber auf jeden Fall irgendein Zusammenspiel. Aber
das Dumme ist... Stimmt, wir können mal im Log gucken. Das stimmt schon, hast du recht.
Das Blöde ist, ich will ja 3D-Acceleration haben. Wegen Animationen und sowas.
Guck mal hier. Please release. Alles klar, nice. Vmware. Das ist irgendwas im Problem
mit... Was aber cool ist, in meiner normalen VM ist überhaupt kein Problem. Es liegt wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal an irgendwelchen 3D-Acceleration-Geschichten, sondern weil die Probleme haben. Das probieren
wir jetzt tatsächlich mal aus. Aber das ist kacke, wenn du 3D-Acceleration... Wie stehst
du zu Tiling Wind? Ich benutze normalerweise nur Tiling Wind und Manager. Ich mag auch
keine andere Oberfläche so wirklich. Wie man heute wieder gesehen hat, dass da vieles
ziemlich abfuck ist. Wobei ich das hier bis jetzt eigentlich ganz brauchbar finde. Ich
habe eine Idee. Wisst ihr was wir noch probieren können? Wir können mal in die Settings gehen.
Wo ging das im Firefox-Hardware? Hier, so. So ging das im Firefox, genau. Q-Teil müssten
wir auch mal ausprobieren. Es gibt ja noch Community-Editions davon. Ach ja, das ist
ein Problem mit Firefox. Immer noch geil. Das ist ein Problem mit Firefox. Wenn Firefox
komische Dinge machen will mit der Firefox-Grafikkarte, dann ist es kaputt. Okay, wir können mal gucken,
wie das mit Chrome aussieht. Ob Chrome damit auch Probleme hätte? Gucken wir mal. Also,
ich habe ja hier in meiner Form tatsächlich auch Hardware-Beschleunigung aus, in meiner
normalen. Machen wir das mal an. Vielleicht liegt das doch einfach in der neuen Firefox-Version,
dass die irgendwie rumbackt. YouTube, genau, das wollen wir haben. Nee, die sind drauf.
Sonst würde der Bildschirm gar nicht resizeen. Okay, in meiner V-M geht das auch mit. Hat
überhaupt keine Probleme. Außer Bild, irgendwelche komischen Bugs. Das liegt bestimmt an einem
Zusammenspiel aus den üblichen Sachen, die es da unter Linux gibt, wo es sich dann immer
ein bisschen gegenseitig die Schuld zu schieben. Es liegt an Hardware-Treibern, es liegt an
der Mesa-Implementierung, es liegt am Browser, es liegt am Codec, was auch immer. Also aus
irgendeiner blöden Zusammenstellung, Kombination aus Browser-Version, Driver-Version, Kernel-Version,
keine Ahnung. Irgendwas wird es wahrscheinlich sein, warum es bei mir ohne Probleme in der
V-M geht und hier abkackt mit 3D Accelerator bzw. Hardware-Beschleunigung unter Firefox.
Mesa wird in Rust neu geschrieben, ja. Dann ist es hoffentlich auch Blazingly Fast. So,
schauen wir mal, was denn Chrome dazu sagt. Ja, genau. Excepte alles. Chrome sagt dazu,
dass es ohne Probleme funktioniert. Scheint mir also ein reines Firefox-Pepega-Ding zu
sein. Na gut. Tweemoji müssen wir installieren. Ohne Tweemoji gibt es im Chrome keine Emojis
und das geht nicht. Emojis ist das Allerwichtigste, wie wir alle wissen. Oh. Immer noch nicht.
Okay. Aber da sind sie doch. Ach, da oben rennt er. Scheiß drauf. Okay, wunderbar. Also
da funktioniert das. Budgee Desktop an sich finde ich bis jetzt gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich mag hier immer noch mein E3. Scheint mir aber noch ganz brauchbar zu sein. Ja,
ich wollte mir irgendein Video vorhin angucken. Hab ich schon wieder ganz vergessen. Reddit.
Hat irgendeiner was gepostet. Reddit. Ah, das ist nicht mehr drin. Aber ich hab es glücklicherweise
noch hier offen, weil ich es vorhin aufgemacht habe. Du musst es nicht auch mal posten. Ich
hab es. Okay. Hyperland. Nein, darfst nicht Reddit. Hyperland. Rised Up. Oh, was ein
Startbildschirm. Was ein Startbildschirm. Kackel. Da geht es ja schon mal richtig los.
Was ein Startvideo. Okay. Könnte KDE mit Tiling mein E3 ersetzen? Vielleicht, aber
ich sehe da überhaupt keine Veranlassung zu. Och, sehr stylisch, Leute. Sehr stylisch.
Ist das Pauli Bar oder ist das bei Hyperland dabei? Ach, du Scheiße. Das ist cool. Das
ist cool. Ja, ganz wichtig. Das hat was. Das hat schon irgendwo was. Ist das in der
Mitte Sound oder ist es eine CPU-Auslastung wegen den ganzen Animationen? Hat was. Hat
was. Hat was. Doch, gefällt mir ganz gut. Es ist zwar sehr verspielt und eigentlich Overkill,
aber man muss es ja auch nicht so krass übertreiben wie der Dude hier. Also, ich würde es bestimmt
nicht so übertrieben. Stylen mit Animationen und allem, aber die eine oder andere Sache
ist bestimmt ganz nett. Ich glaube, ich muss es mal ausprobieren. Jetzt nicht heute, aber
guckt mal hier. Wie heißt das Ding? Hyperland. Das haben wir ja gerade schon angeguckt. Hyperland
ist highly customized. Okay, gibt es ein Endeavor OS? Alter, ich kann das nicht mal richtig
schreiben. Hyperland. Best install method. Ja, das kriege ich natürlich auch hin. Okay,
wollen wir das mal schnell installieren und gucken, ob es funktioniert. Jetzt ohne großartig
einzustellen. Hyperland bin. Beta. Was hältst du von dem komischen Glow? Du meinst, dass
der Hintergrund sich ein bisschen dem Videoinhalt anpasst? Oder wie? Oder was meinst du? Genau.
Finde ich ganz nett. Gebraucht hätte ich es nicht. Okay, jetzt haben wir Hyperland installiert.
Mal schauen, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Lockout. Nein. Lockout. Yes. Zack. Hyperland.
Macht es jetzt was? Da ist was. Ja, da ist was. Ja, da ist was. Ja, da ist was. Ja,
da ist was. Oder ist es die vm? Scheint gekrascht zu sein. Okay, nice. Extremely Hyperland.
Bestimmt 0 FPS Mod. Scheint. Warum kann ich jetzt nicht mal das Desktop Environment auswählen
da unten? Exploded. Brauchen wir nicht mehr. Getting started. Vm. In a vm make sure you
have 3D acceleration enabled. Ja. Okay, das ist anscheinend nicht so einfach, das in Betrieb
zu bekommen, wie es aussieht. Wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal den verbleibenden. Das machen
wir heute nicht. Das probieren wir andere mal aus. Vielleicht geht es aber in a vm gar
nicht gescheit, was aber echt doof wäre, wenn es nicht ordentlich in a vm geht. Ist
doch gdm? Ja. Ist das ein Problem? Wir können das ändern. Wir können. Okay, LXQT. Wir können
ausprobieren. Welcome to please select the default window manager. Wir nehmen mal irgendwas.
Guck mal, da kannst du starrer mich sogar. Compits nehmen. Poggers. Openbox. Dann kommt
es einem nicht in die Quere. Hier konnte man noch change display manager. Was hat der
Typ gesagt auf reddit, was man nehmen soll? ssdm, lxdm, lite dm. Ssdm. Reboot is required.
Okay, das sieht tatsächlich auch sehr oldschool aus. Ist das ein xfce fork oder so? Es sieht
aus wie ein oldschool xfce. Okay, das ist jetzt... Aber xfce war doch gnome. Das ist
Qterminal. Okay, das sieht tatsächlich ein bisschen aus wie Windows 95, aber ich finde
gar nicht mal so mies. Das erinnert mich total an altes xfce. Oder? Oder? Ne, an altes kde
auch nicht wirklich. Search. Nice. Auch schon sehr oldschool. Okay, dann starten wir das
mal neu. Wo ist der Knopf zum Neustarten? Leave. Reboot. Ah ne, Moment. Reboot. Gucken
wir mal, ob Hyperland jetzt startet. Wir können ja mal kurz suchen. Sekunde. Hyperland. Vor
immer Workstation, ob es da Bugs drinne gibt. Vor immer Workstation. Ah, ich hab Hardware
Acceleration noch an. Da scheint der Pepo manchmal im Hintergrund durch. Deswegen hab
ich Hardware Acceleration noch ausgeschaltet, weil das rumbuckt. Das scheint ziemlich, das
scheint ziemlich high IQ zu sein. Was hat das jetzt damit zu tun? Das hat er doch schon
gemacht, oder? Okay. Max und jetzt hier genau um Hyper. Hyperland. Machen wir heute noch
Set Servers? Ne. Leute, es ist broken. Es geht nicht. Es tut nicht. Es ist kaputt. Hyperland.
Das mag hier drinnen nicht. Aber Acceleration haben wir noch an. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich Reboote
mal kurz. Okay, wir haben uns jetzt eigentlich alles angeguckt an Desktop Umgebung oder
haben wir noch eins vergessen? Was haben wir noch vergessen? Eins haben wir noch offen,
glaube ich. Hallo, kannst du mal neu starten, please? Na, Community Editions, glaube ich.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht gucken wir noch mal kurz in Community Editions rein, was wir
da haben. Vielleicht gibt es ja eine Hyperland. Cinnamon haben wir noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ja, gut. Gut, den kennen wir. Den haben wir, glaube ich, in Mint uns vor nicht allzu langer
Zeit mal angeguckt. Rest haben wir ausprobiert. Also ich muss sagen, KDE hat mir tatsächlich
rein optisch von dem, wie es vorkonviel war, bis jetzt noch am besten gefallen. Das geht
auch klar hier. Das geht auch klar. Lass mal kurz gucken, was macht hier? Was macht hier
Firefox? Okay, Firefox funktioniert hier auch. Burger King. Worms. Nee, ich wollte mich ja,
ich habe mich gefragt, was das ist. Das hier macht auch einen ganz guten Eindruck. Das scheint
man doch benutzen zu können. Was hat denn das für Sterne GitHub? Desktop. Okay. Nee,
das war was anderes. Ja, das ist tatsächlich ziemlich... Ich will den Network Manager öffnen.
Das ist das ganz normale Network Manager Applet, was es überall gibt. Das sieht tatsächlich
ganz brauchbar aus. Ich denke, damit könnte man auch arbeiten. Also wenn man einen der
klassischen Desktops da wirklich haben will, kriegt man irgendwie Desktop-Icons? New Folder?
Okay, also Icons auf den Desktop ist immer noch absolut böse. Das will keiner haben.
Overrated, debated. Braucht man nicht. Kann man das auf die Leiste? Nee. Ich meine, unter
Windows 11 geht das auch nicht. Also insofern... Als wenn Windows das Master-Dinge ist, dann
ist das ja normal. Das ist auch Nemo hier. Nee, das ist Kaya. Da haben wirklich alle
vom gleichen File Manager geforkt, oder? Die sehen alle so gleich und ähnlich sich aus.
Was haben wir hier neben für einen Knopf? Hier haben wir neben einen Knopf, der Knopf
ist und man nicht weiß, was das macht. Wie sehen Notifications aus? Das macht doch einen
ganz brauchbaren Eindruck hier. Ich glaube, das könnte man verwenden. Ah ja, das könnte
Show Desktops sein, du hast recht. Moment, und wo sehe ich jetzt, was offen ist? Och
nee, please. Windows 11 nachgebaut. Immerhin steht da noch was dran. Das kann man aber
wahrscheinlich... Das kann man wahrscheinlich ändern. Wenn ich jetzt Hyperland starte, gar
nix, läuft da schon nix, aber... Nee, so viel kann man da auch nicht einstellen. Haben
die wirklich das nervigste Feature von Windows 11 übernommen und sich gedacht, das ist eine
gute Idee. Remove Crooped Window List, okay. Yes, oh. Und wie kriegt man das jetzt wieder
hin? Ah, hier gibt es eine Window List, excellent. Ja, sehr schön, okay. Und? Jemand pfeifert
und weiß, wie man das jetzt verschiebt? Okay, das finde ich schonmal deutlich angenehmer
als der Kramunterwinner aus 11. Move. Wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wie ich das verschiebe,
dann fände ich das schonmal nice. Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das funktionieren
muss eigentlich. Jetzt kann man hier drüber kein Terminal mehr starten. Guck mal, das
füllt sich jetzt von der falschen Seite auf. Das müsste sich von links nach rechts auffüllen.
Applet Preferences, Configure, Window List. Okay, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es
geht. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie. Aber das kann man tatsächlich ganz gut benutzen. Ich denke,
damit kommt man, wenn man es wirklich haben will, damit ganz gut klar. Aber es ist mal
wieder nichts dabei, was irgendwie für mich Konkurrenz zu meinem i3 machen könnte. Leute,
bevor wir auffüllen, ich probiere nochmal was. Ich installiere jetzt Hyperland bei mir
in der normalen VM. Ich habe vorher einen Screenshot gemacht. Was installiere ich? Hyperland
bin, Hyperland normal, Hyperland Git, Hyperland normal installieren. Da kompiliert das selbst
bei dem anderen oder das dauert einfach nur drei, drei Wochen. Egal, wir kompilieren
selbst easy. Ich habe einen Snapshot gemacht, da kann nichts. Aber der muss jetzt auch Wayland
und so installieren, oder? Leute, ich sehe schon, das wird nichts. Hyperland Start, Quickstart,
wrapping the launch. Ich kann auch gleich Hyperland ausführen. Probieren wir mal aus.
Schon fertig, schon fertig. Das ging aber schnell. Hyperland, alles klar. Okay, dann
machen wir mal Hyperstart.sh. Kopieren das einfach ein Java. Ist das in Java programmiert?
Nee, oder? Das ist doch bestimmt. Placing the fast written in Rust, weil alle coolen
Leute was in Rust machen, oder? Nee, C++, auch gut. Wobei, bin ich mir nicht sicher,
aber auch gut. CRMOD plus X. Hyperstart. Okay, das ist anscheinend normal, dass das
Blackscreen ist. InnerVM. Das crasht aber nicht. Kann das sein, dass es einfach keine
Konfig hat und einfach nur leer ist? Dass man da gar nichts sieht, dass das normal ist?
Aber abgekackt ist es schon mal nett. Abgekackt ist es nicht, es läuft hier noch. Ich starte
mal kurz neu. Jaja, hab ich, hab ich. Hab ich. Hyperland. Blackscreen. Jawoll.
Aha. Run, Running Hyper ist unsupported. Wir haben es erbaut. If Running Hyper. Okay.
Okay. Irgendjemand hat auch eben einen Link gepostet, wo der Typ was erzählt hat von
wegen. Man soll in seiner VM irgendwas durchreichen oder sowas. Also was sollen wir machen? Wl-Render,
was? Wl-Render. Okay, das wird aber abverklangsam sein. Also mit Software will ich das bestimmt
nicht übertreiben. Also mit Software Rendering. So? Wir brauchen bestimmt irgendeine Konfig,
dass man überhaupt was sieht. Was, was macht der denn, wenn man das startet normalerweise
zum ersten Mal? Egal, das machen wir heute nicht. Das machen wir heute nicht. Das gucken
wir uns irgendwie andermal an. Ich restore jetzt den Snapshot, wie der ungut ist.
Wenn man es normal schaltet, gibt ihr das eine Default-Konfig mit fetten Warning-Screen.
Das ist eine Default-Konfig. Ah ja, okay. Aber es ist nicht einfach. Es ist nicht einfach
Black-Screen. Okay, verstehe, verstehe. Alles klar, Leute. Gut. Hat mich tatsächlich mal
wieder überzeugt, dass ich am besten dran bin mit meiner ordentlichen, mit meinem ordentlichen
Tiling-Window-Manager selbst konfiguriert. Alles andere fuckt mich ab. Und irgendwie gibt
es an vielen Stellen wieder Probleme, wo ich eigentlich keine Probleme erwarten würde.
Fenster, die nach links gehen, wenn man nach rechts zieht und sowas. Das ist doch nichts.
Also ich bleibe dabei. Ich mag weder KDE noch GNOME noch sonst irgendeine andere Oberfläche
unter Linux. Das einzige, mit dem ich klarkomme, ist tatsächlich mein i3 und sonst nichts.
Ja, blöd, aber gut. Ich probiere jetzt vielleicht noch ein bisschen offscreen den Kram hier
noch zum Laufen zu bekommen. Gibt es da vielleicht Möglichkeiten? Gucken wir mal. Hast du mal
Awesome probiert? Ja, aber nie wirklich lang. Pangolin Desktop? Okay, weil du es bist. Pangolin
Desktop. Okay, ist ja schon mal sehr vertrauenswürdige Packages. Alles outdated. Das da anscheinend.
Ich installiere das jetzt auf meiner normalen VM, weil ich habe hier meinen Snapshot, den
kann ich ja einfach revorten. Yes. Oh. Nope. Eigen 3. Was zum Teufel ist Eigen 3? Das mache
ich jetzt nicht. Das mache ich jetzt nicht, wenn ich es nicht einfach installieren lasse.
Nope, keine Chance. Das ist nicht der Desktop? Ach so. Sigma Chat. Das hat überhaupt keine
Sterne und gar nichts. Sicher, dass das also sonderlich. Moment, also sonderlich. Sonderlich
tolles, erfolgreiches, bekanntes Projekt kann es doch nicht sein. 1,7 Sterne. So, das muss
man. Okay, normale Installationsanleitung gibt es da gar nicht. Okay, komm einfach hier.
Was ist denn die letzte Version? Packages Releases 2021, man. Okay, wir machen drei,
oder geht. Okay, Leute, wir machen Java. Also, weil, okay, Leute, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Keine Chance. Ich gehe jetzt auf. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, Leute. Macht es gut.
Bis dann, see you.